in this course valentine will teach you
how to use gitlab ci to build ci cd
pipelines to build and deploy software
to aws
hello freecode campers and welcome to
this course which will introduce you to
gitlab ci and devops my name is
valentine i'm a software developer and i
like to share my passion for technology
with others in a way that is easy to
understand when i'm not speaking at a
conference
or traveling the world
i like to share what i know by being
active in groups and forums and creating
tutorials on youtube or online courses
in this course we will understand what
gitlab ci is and why we need this tool
and start building ci cd pipelines
during the course we'll create a
pipeline that takes a simple website
builds a container tests it and deploys
it to the amazon web services cloud
also called aws
in other words we'll be focusing on
automation i've created this course for
people new to devops who want to use
gitlab to build test and deploy their
software
don't worry if none of this makes sense
right now if you're a beginner that is
totally fine you don't need to install
any tools or anything else also no
coding knowledge is required but if you
have some it is great it will help a bit
i will explain to you everything you
need to know step by step
this course focuses on gitlab ci but the
course notes are packed with resources i
recommend exploring if unfamiliar with a
specific topic go right now to the video
description and open the course notes
there you will find important resources
and troubleshooting tips if something
goes wrong
i will also be publishing there any
corrections additions and modifications
yes this is a very dynamic industry and
things change all the time so if
something is not working
first check the course notes
i'm a big fan of learning by doing and
you will get hands-on experience
building pipelines and deploying
software to aws throughout the course i
will give you assignments to practice
what you have learned
while in this course we'll be focusing
on a specific technology and cloud
provider what you're actually learning
are the concepts around devops with the
skills acquired in this course i'm sure
you'll be able to start using gitlab ci
for whatever you need in no time at all
this is an action-packed course which
i'm sure will keep you busy at least for
a few days
as always here on freecodecamp please
help us make such courses available to
you by liking and subscribing also don't
forget to drop a comment below the video
if you like this course i invite you to
check out and subscribe to my youtube
channel link in the video description
which is packed with content around
devops software development and testing
also feel free to connect with me on
social media i would really love to hear
from you
finally i would like to thank those who
will support free code camp by clicking
that thanks button and making a small
donation i hope you're excited to learn
more about gitlab ci aws and devops and
with that being said let's get started
i have designed this course to be as
easy to follow along as possible you
don't need to install any software on
your computer and you should be able to
do everything just from a browser i'll
be using gitlab.com throughout the
course if you don't have a gitlab.com
account please go ahead and create one
by default you will get a free trial
with your account which will be
downgraded to a free one after 30 days
it just takes a few steps to create an
account
if you don't want to participate in the
free trial that's totally fine there's
also the possibility of skipping the
trial altogether
gitlab is a platform that offers git
repositories where we store code
and code pipelines which help us build
software projects
now that the registration process is
completed let's begin by creating our
first project
and we're going to create a blank
project
i'm going to call this project my first
pipeline
i have the option of providing a project
description which is optional
and i can also decide on the project
visibility either private which means
that only i or people who i explicitly
grant access to can view this project or
public which means that can be viewed by
anyone without any authentication
i will not gonna initialize this project
with a readme file
i'm gonna simply go ahead and click
create project
this gitlab project allows us to store
files and to use git to keep track of
changes and also to collaborate with
others on this project
if the concepts around git are not clear
check the course notes for a free course
on getting started with git for gitlab
since for this account i haven't
configured git you will also get here
this warning in regards to adding the
ssh key this is also covered in the
material i have mentioned but for the
moment we don't need this so we can
simply discard it
the first thing that i like to do is to
change a few settings in regards to how
this interface looks like so from the
user profile
i will go to preferences
and
here from the syntax highlighting theme
what i like to do is to select monokai
so this is essentially a dark theme
and as you probably know we like to use
dark themes because light attracts bugs
and we definitely don't want any bugs
now leaving the joker side some people
like it some people don't like it i
prefer to use a dark theme when writing
code but totally agree that depends on
everyone's preference on how to use this
there are also some other settings i
want you to do right now in the
beginning
i'm going to scroll here a bit further
down
and the first thing that i want you to
enable is render white space characters
in web ide
this will show us any white space
characters whenever editing files that's
super important okay we have everything
that we need to do so i'm gonna go all
the way to the bottom
click on save changes
and go back to gitlab
you'll see here your projects so
currently have only one project i'm
going to click on it
and currently we have absolutely no code
inside this project
the first thing that i want to do is to
begin to create a file so from this new
gitlab project we're going to use the
web ide to create the pipeline
definition file i'm going to click here
on new file
this will open up the gitlab ide
so i'm going to create a new file
and we are already provided here with a
template
and this file name must be called dot
gitlab dash ci dot yaml it's not exactly
this name if you're writing it on your
own
this pipeline will not be recognized so
the pipeline fine will not be recognized
by gitlab this is a very common mistake
that beginners make
probably this is why if you click
directly on this one
you'll be pretty sure that you don't
name this file like anything else now in
this file we're gonna define the
pipelines and essentially gonna
write here configuration to create
pipelines in gitlab say
it's totally fine if you don't know what
that is right now just to create a very
simple example to make sure that we have
everything we need in order to follow
along with the rest of the course so
what i'm going to do here i'm going to
write something like test
column
and then i'm going to go to the next
line
and you will see here everything is
already indented
so with this indentation with this four
spaces that you can see right now here
i'm gonna write script
column
space
and then i'm going to use the echo
command to display a text
this is going to be the text that we
want to display
the echo command is used to display a
text and we'll be able to see it later
on and this dot gitlab ci that yaml file
allows us to describe our pipeline
as i said don't worry if this does not
make any sense right now this is just a
test to ensure we have everything we
need to get started
so now what we're gonna do is to
actually commit these changes
which means introducing this file inside
the gitlab repository
if we click again here on the project
name we'll exit this view
and you will see here
that the pipeline failed so every time
we make changes to this project the
pipeline will be executed based what we
have defined
in this yaml file
but you will see here right on top
there's this indication that something
is wrong
and even here if you look inside the
pipeline
you will get this additional information
so what is going on
in order to run your pipeline using the
gitlab.com infrastructure
you need to verify your account now this
is not the same as verifying your email
address you already did that but you
need to go an additional step of
verification
unfortunately some people decided to
take advantage of this free service and
have abused it for mining cryptocurrency
for the time being you will be asked to
verify your account using a credit card
now your credit card will not be charged
or stored by gitlab and it is used
solely for verifying your account just
to ensure that you are one of the good
guys and i know that you're one of the
good guys and i know that this is a bit
annoying in the beginning
but this is how things are right now
i also know that credit cards are not
that widespread in some countries and
this may be inconvenient
maybe you can ask a friend to help out
i hope that gitlab will introduce
alternative verification options
nevertheless verifying your gitlab.com
account and using the gitlab.com
infrastructure is the easiest way to
follow along with the course
so if you can invest five minutes now
and get this done
it will save you hours later
you can use your own infrastructure to
run gitlab but it is more complex and
from my experience of training thousands
of students is that people new to gitlab
who use their own infrastructure have
issues running their pipelines and waste
a lot of time trying to get them to run
properly you have been warned but if you
want to go this path i've added some
resources to the course notes which you
can find in the video description
now in order to get started with a
verification process you have to click
here on validate account
you will be asked to enter your credit
card information
i hope that the validation has been okay
and in order to see if everything is
working properly i'm gonna go back to
the project and open the web ide
i'm gonna click on the get lab ci
file to make a change to it and i'm
gonna change here the message so this is
gonna be now hello world 2
and going to go here commit
so essentially making a new change to
this file and commit it directly into
the main branch
and if i'm looking here at the bottom
i should be able to see that something
is happening so very soon a pipeline
will be started
and you will see here now pipeline with
the specific number is running i can
click on it
and if you click here on this execution
you'll be able to see the job logs
and what we're interested in is firstly
seeing this message here hello world
and additionally what we're also
interested in seeing here
is
seeing this text here which says pulling
docker image now this is very important
not for this job itself but what we are
going to do throughout the course we
want to make sure that whatever we have
here in terms of the execution that we
are actually using docker
if this is working it's fantastic you
can jump directly into the next lecture
otherwise check the course notes for
some troubleshooting ideas
so what is a pipeline allow me to make
an analogy to an assembly line used to
manufacture a physical product
any product goes through a series of
steps
let's take a laptop for example
to oversimplify the assembly line would
have the following steps
would take an empty laptop body case
we'll add the main board we'll add a
keyboard
we would do some quality assurance to
ensure it turns on and works properly
then we would put it in a box and
finally ship it to customers
and we are not using gitlab to produce
physical products we want to build
software
but producing software has similarities
to what i have described before
before we can ship anything we go
through a series of steps
let's try to build the laptop assembly
line in gitlab ci well kind of instead
of real components we'll use a file a
folder and some text
so let's begin with the first task
take an empty laptop case
we'll put this in a job
in gitlab a job is a set of commands we
want to execute
so now let's go back to our project and
make some changes to it again i'm gonna
open the web id to be able to view the
pipeline file now essentially we already
have a job here but we're gonna expand
this and make it
build a laptop
if you're facing any issues getting the
following steps to run make sure to
watch the next lesson where i'm going
over some of the most common mistakes
now we already have a job and this job
is called test
but probably we should go ahead and
rename this to maybe build a laptop
or we can also call it simply build
laptop now in the script part this is
where we can
essentially write commands now so far we
have used this echo command
but the way we written this
allows us only to write one command so
what i'm gonna do here i'm gonna go on
the next line
and i'm gonna start here with the dash
and this will allow us to
essentially write multiple commands one
after the other
so let's rename this in something like
building a laptop just to give us some
information in regards to what we're
trying to do
i want you to notice that after this
dash i have added a space and you can
see that space represented by a dot
common mistake that people just getting
started with gitlab
and
this language that you see here which is
called yamo
is that they don't add the spaces or
they don't properly indent what they see
so make sure that what you have inside
your editor
looks pretty much the same as what i
have here and you're doing that pretty
sure this example will also work for you
now as i said the language that we're
using here to describe our pipeline is
called yaml
and yaml is essentially a way to
represent key value pairs
it may look a bit weird in the beginning
but after a few examples i'm sure you
will get used to it now so far our
problem doesn't do anything and inside
this job we actually said we want to
build this laptop
and we also said that we're not going to
use physical components we're going to
use folders we're going to use files
we're going to use some text
so let's begin with the first command
which will create a new folder
now we want to put this into a folder
which is called build so on the next
line i'm gonna use a command that will
create a folder this command is called
make deer
and i'm going to call this folder build
so now we have a folder and let's go to
the next line and actually create a file
so i want my file to be inside this
build folder
and in order to create this file we're
going to use the touch command now the
touch command is generally used for
modifying the timestamp of a file
essentially you're touching it you're
modifying it
but it also has an interesting behavior
which we will use here if the file does
not exist it will create an empty file
and initially for us that's perfectly
fine so we're going to create this file
inside the build folder which we created
one step before and with the forward
slash we'll go inside this build folder
we can specify the file name
which in this case will be computer.txt
now the next question is how do we get
some text inside this file
and in order to do that we're going to
use a command we have already used
before and this is the echo command now
echo if we don't do anything else like
we did here
it will just print this message and
we'll see it in our build logs
but we can also kind of redirect this
and send it directly to a file and for
that we're going to use an operator so
let me show you what i mean by that i'm
going to write here again echo
and the first thing that we are going to
do
is we're going to add here the main
board now let's say the file itself it's
just containing the the laptop and then
we're adding components to it so if you
would keep this as it is right now
it will just display this information
just display mainboard but we actually
want to get it inside this file that you
see here so i'm simply going to go ahead
and copy it
and in order to get this text inside
there we're going to use this operator
it's actually greater than greater than
and essentially this operator takes the
output from one command so echo
is one command
and it will append it
to a specified file so now we have
specified here this computer.txt file
which is inside the build folder
so if you want to take a look and see
exactly what is the contents of the file
we can do that as well
and for that we there are different
commands that we can use one option
would be to use the cat command
and
cat stands for concatenate and can be
used for creating displaying or
modifying the contents of files in this
case we're using this hat command to
view the contents of a file and again we
have to specify the path to that file
so just to make sure i don't make any
mistakes
and always go ahead and copy paste
the value
of the file the name of the file and of
course we can also go ahead and add the
other steps so which other steps did we
had
for example we wanted to add a keyboard
i'm gonna add this again with a new
command
and
i think that should be it's a way we
have the main board we have the keyboard
and of course we can also try this cat
command once again at the end and this
will give us an idea of how the job
itself is working
in the previous execution we haven't
specified a docker image to use
and by default it will download a ruby
docker image which for our use case here
doesn't really make a lot of sense so
we're going to use a very simple docker
image it's a linux distribution that
will be started with our job
and we can do that by specifying here
another keyword
and you will see here it's under the job
itself which is build laptop
but at the same level with the script so
i'm going to write here image
column and the image name will be alpine
so alpine linux is a very lightweight
linux distribution what's most important
for us that this distribution has these
commands that we're using so these are
pretty standard commands that are
available essentially in any linux
distribution
but having a very small linux
distribution will make our job run much
faster
so let's go ahead commit these changes
and see how the pipeline runs
i'm going to commit again to the main
branch and if i'm in patient i can click
directly here on the pipeline
or i can also go directly on the project
page
and you will only see here the pipeline
running
pipeline is also available if you go
here inside cicd pipelines
it will display your list of all the
pipelines that are running
you can click here on this one which is
the id of the pipeline you will see now
our pipeline contains a job
and this job has been assigned to the
stage test
by default if no stage is defined
the job will use the test stage
now it doesn't really matter how the
name of the stage has been called
we just want to make sure that the
commands that we have executed are
actually working properly we're getting
here no errors so the job is running
so the job has executed successfully we
can click on it take a look at the
execution logs
see exactly what has happened here
and you will see here in the logs the
commands that we have executed they're
all visible
here you will see here echo building
laptop you will see the text being
displayed
after that we are creating a new folder
we're putting a file inside that folder
we're adding some text to that file then
we're checking the contents of the file
to make sure everything is fine you'll
see here the word main board being
displayed
and then we add the keyboard
and then again you will see here the
contents of the file containing both
main board and keyboard
so what is a pipeline it is a set of
jobs organized in stages
right now we have a single job that
belongs to the test stage however in the
upcoming lectures we'll be expanding
this pipeline
it is quite common that when you are
just getting started with defining these
pipelines that you make some mistakes
let me show you like some common
mistakes that will lead to invalid
configuration which will lead to gitlab
not running your pipeline
i'm going to make this a bit bigger on
the screen so that you can easily check
and compare it with what you have
it's very important that in some places
you have this column so for example here
i'm defining the job
and in order to add image and scripts as
essentially properties of this job it's
important to have here this column
if i'm removing that you will see here
in the editor when you see these lines
here it will indicate
that something is wrong most of the time
these messages are really not so easy to
understand so it's more important to
double check what you have written here
to make sure it is exactly as it should
be
it's also important that you have some
spaces where there are spaces expected
so for example
here with the commands and whenever
you're writing echo or make deer or
touch there needs to be a space between
the dash and the command this is why in
the beginning i've asked you to enable
this white spaces so that you can easily
see them in your script so if i write
something like this
this again
will make something weird so it will not
show here an error because this is
actually
valid yamo
but
when gitlab will try to execute this
pipeline and we'll look at these
commands we'll think that you're trying
to run a command that starts with dash
echo
and we'll say i cannot find this command
so for that reason you need this space
here to make a difference between
this dash here which indicates a list
and this command
what's also important is the indentation
as you can notice here there are four
spaces
so everything that is under build laptop
is indented with the level if i add
something like this here
it it will no longer belong to build
laptop and will come out as something
that's really weird and most likely it
will be invalid so always make sure that
you have the right indentation
two spaces are also fine by default this
web ide will use four spaces
just make sure you have that indentation
there in place
in the course notes you will find even
more examples of why your pipeline may
be failing
including some common error codes that
you may encounter
so definitely check the course notes if
you're still having issues getting this
pipeline to run
in this lesson we'll try to understand
what yaml is if you already know yaml
feel free to skip this as i will not be
covering any advanced features
the most important reason why you need
to know some yaml basics is because
you'll be facing many errors while
writing yaml
and as i mentioned in the beginning this
is normal trust me i also did the same
mistakes that you did
and sometimes i'm still making mistakes
while writing yaml if i'm not paying
attention if you've already been exposed
to formats such as json or xml
i'm sure you'll be able to understand
the basics around yaml very easily
actually yaml is a superset of json and
you can easily convert json to yaml
both xml json and yaml
are human readable data interchange
formats
while json is very easy to
generate and parse
typically yaml is considered easier to
read
as you will see not so easy to write but
we'll get to that
quite often yaml is being used for
storing configuration
especially if you're learning devops you
probably face yaml a lot and this is
exactly why we're using it in gitlab as
well to store a pipeline configuration
at its core yaml follows key value
storage principles and let me open up
here inside the editor a new file and
i'm gonna start writing some yaml basics
so i'm gonna create here file i'm gonna
call it
test.yaml and let's start with a few
basics so for example how do we
represent a key value pair so for
example i have here a name
typically would write something like the
name is john right
so this is something that anyone would
understand now in yaml we use a column
to separate that
and so i'm going to add here name column
john
and what's also more important that we
have a space after this column so it
will be like this and you will see here
the color here will also change so now
we have a key value pair the key is name
and the value is john
we also call this a mapping we're
mapping a key with a value
of course on a new line we can start
adding an additional key value pair for
example let's say here h
23
and what's important to know is that the
order of the properties does not matter
so we can define them in any order so if
i write
first name john and after that h or the
other way around
that's actually the same both are
defined here in this yaml
quite often we need to define lists
which in yaml are called sequences and
we do that by writing each value on a
new line
so for example let's
write here some hobbies call them sports
youtube
and hiking
right
and what you also do is we put them each
of them on a new line but each line must
start with a dash and a space so we have
here a dash and a space
a dash and a space
dash and a space
now we have a list
now the way i've written this doesn't
really work like that so if we remove
everything from here this will be
probably a valid list
but we cannot simply just combine this
properties and now just add this list
here in between
what's important to know about yaml is
that it uses indentation for scope
essentially it
allows you to know which value belongs
to which key
because it has the proper indentation so
for example now we know this is not
valid here
but if you write here for example
hobbies
as a key
then this list here
will belong to this key
so essentially the mapping will contain
a key and this list of values
well this is valid we also like to
indent this i'm going to select
everything and click on tab and this
will indent all these values here
additionally we can have some nested
structures so for example if i'm trying
to write here an address
so this will be the key and then on a
new line i can write additional key
value pairs which all belong to the
address and you will see here i have the
indentation so i can write something
like street
and on a new line i can go ahead and
write a city
and again on a new line i'm gonna write
here the zip code
and
essentially by using this indentation we
show that street city and zip they all
belong to address if we didn't have this
indentation and it would all be a
property of something else
this is why in this case we're using
here name age hobbies and address these
are like
properties on the first level
and
street city and zip they are under
address
in terms of lists we can also build some
more advanced lists so this is a very
simple list that we've used for hobbies
but let's say for example that we want
to
add here a new key which is called
experience
and here uh for the experience we're
gonna create a list
and
we just wanna say like what is the
professional experience of this person
for example we can have here job title
that could be junior developer
and
instead of creating here a new item in
the list
we just go to the same level as with
title
then we can start writing something like
period
so it will indicate in which period
this person has been a junior developer
let's say from 2000 to 2005.
and then we can go ahead and add a new
item to the list
again with title
let's say now this person is a senior
developer and we can also define a
different period
so this will be
since 2005.
now additionally what we can do is
we can take everything that we have here
and
how about we define here let's say this
is a person
right
and then we can take every everything
that we have here and indent it once
and then all these properties that we
have here will belong to a person now
you can see here that we are still have
some mistakes here so we can
we need to fix something because this
editor will tell us this is a bad
indentation and as you learn indentation
is very very important so i'm going to
add here to spaces
and add here again to spaces
and now this indentation will be correct
now when we are writing gitlab ci
pipelines we don't really get to choose
which data structures to use
we have the liberty of designing the
pipeline but we need to do it in a way
that gitlab will understand it
so if we're looking here at our pipeline
we can just decide to use something else
so for example instead of image we
cannot just decide we're going to call
it docker image or docker or instead of
scripts we cannot write here scripts
because this is something that gitlab
will not understand yes from a yaml
perspective this is still valid but from
the perspective of gitlab this is
something that's not according to
what we agreed essentially in advance
when we started writing these pipelines
so it's just important that you
understand like what we're doing here
and how this indentation and how this
key value pairs are being written
but when we're writing jobs we we decide
how this job will be named we decide
what exactly will happen inside it some
keys will be reserved and simply cannot
be renamed you just have to pay
attention that what you're writing here
is really important and it has to be
exactly at least exactly as the examples
that i'm showing you otherwise gitlab
will not be able to understand what
you're
seeing throughout the course we'll be
using linux and linux commands
we have already learned some commands
such as echo touch make deer cat and so
on
we typically use these commands through
a command line interface or cli what you
see here
for example i can go ahead and create
here a new folder
i can switch inside that folder
we'll see here for example with ls i
will be able to list the contents of
that folder
let's go ahead and write here touch this
touch command and create here file name
computer
and again with ls i can see which files
are inside the current folder so we
typically type these commands that you
have seen in the pipeline through this
command line interface or cli
sometimes we call it a console a
terminal or a shell
while technically speaking they are not
the same thing you may notice me and
others use them interchangeably
a command line interface is the opposite
of a graphical interface
this is a graphical interface you will
be able to see text colors you have
buttons that you can click
things are happening through your
interaction you're moving your mouse
and you're clicking or something or
you're using your keyboard and something
changes on the screen
this is a command line interface
we will work with the command line
interface to write commands
computers we interact with have no user
interface that we can use
anyway automating graphical user
interfaces is not as easy and as
reliable as simply using commands
the command line interface that
computers have is called the shell
the shell is simply the outer layer of
the system
the only thing that we can see from
outside and interact with
so we send these commands to the system
and the system will run them this is how
we can interact with it
when using gitlab ci we essentially
automate a set of commands which we
execute in a particular order
while i will explain every command that
we'll be using throughout the course
if this is something new there's
absolutely no replacement for trying
things on your own
please see the resources in the course
notes for this lesson on setting up a
linux environment on your own computer
and which linux commands you should know
let's talk for a minute about the gitlab
architecture
at the minimum the gitlab architecture
for working with pipelines contains the
gitlab server
and at least one gitlab runner
the gitlab server manages the execution
of the pipeline and its jobs and stores
the results
the gitlab server knows what needs to be
done
but does not do this itself
when a job needs to be executed it will
find a runner to run the job
a runner is a simple program that
executes the job
a working gitlab setup must have at
least one runner but quite often there
are more of them to help distribute the
load
a runner will retrieve a set of
instructions from the gitlab server
download and start the docker image
specified
get the files from the project git
repository
run all the commands specified in the
job and report back the result of the
execution of the gitlab server
once the job has finished
the docker container will be destroyed
if docker is something new to you check
the course notes for a quick
introduction
what's important to know is that the git
repository of the project will not
contain any of the files created during
the job execution
let's go back to our project you will
see here that inside the git repository
there's no build folder there's no
computer.txt so what exactly is
happening let's go inside one of the
jobs and quickly go through the log so
that you can understand what is going on
so right here on top you'll have
information about
the runner that is executing the job
and a runner will also have an executor
in this case the executor is docker
machine
and here on line four you will see here
which image is being downloaded
and you'll see here pulling docker image
alpine because this is what we have
specified
and then essentially the environment is
being prepared
and then in the upcoming steps
you get the files from the git
repository so essentially all the files
that you have inside the git repository
will also be available here inside the
runner
so after this point the docker container
has been started you have all the
project files and then you start
executing the commands that you have
specified inside the pipeline
so in this case we're creating the
folder we're creating these files we're
putting some text inside there
and then at the end we're not doing
anything else
so the job succeeds because there are no
errors
and
the container is destroyed
so this docker container that has been
created in the beginning just maybe a
few seconds ago
is then destroyed you cannot log into it
you cannot see it anymore it doesn't
exist anymore so it has done its job has
executed this command that we have
specified and then it has been destroyed
since every job runs in a container this
allows for isolation and flexibility
by having our job configuration stored
in the yaml file
we describe how the environment where
the job is running should look like
in practice
we don't know or care which machine has
actually executed the job
also this architecture ensures that we
can add or remove runners as needed
while the gitlab server is a complex
piece of software composed of multiple
services the gitlab runner has a
relatively simple installation and can
run on a dedicated server or even on
your laptop
now right here on top of the job you
have seen some information in regards to
the runner so
the question is where is this job
actually running and to be able to
understand this we'll have to go here to
the project settings
ci cd
and here we're going to expand runners
and you'll see here two categories there
are specific runners
and they are shared runners
now for this job we have used shared
runners
any project can use shared runners
within a gitlab installation
these shares runners are offered by
gitlab.com and are shared between all
users
now as you've seen there are multiple
runners here
and honestly we don't really care which
of these runners picks up our job
because we have defined exactly what our
job should do which docker image we want
to use which command should be executed
so as long as that runner knows how to
deal with a docker image and was able to
execute these commands then we're fine
with any runner
now this is an oversimplified version of
the gitlab architecture the main idea i
want to get from this is that we are
using docker containers in our jobs and
every time for every job
the gitlab runner will start a new
docker container
will execute any commands that we have
and then when the job execution is done
that docker container will be destroyed
so now we have created this laptop and
have defined all the steps inside the
build laptop job
and of course with this cad command we
have also visually verified that indeed
this computer.txt file
contains everything that we expect
but we really want to automate this
process we don't want to go inside the
job itself and to look and see if
everything was successful
so let's expand our pipeline and add a
test job we want to make sure that our
laptop contains all components
so i'm gonna go ahead here and create a
new job
i'm gonna call it test laptop
and we're gonna use the same image the
alpine linux image
and we're gonna also define the script
and this time we need to find a way
to actually
check for example if this file has
indeed been created so this would be
like a very basic test
and
what we can do here is to use the test
command so the test command
will allow us to check if this file has
been created
and this command also has a flag
which we're gonna write with dash f
and then we'll specify the path to the
file
so essentially
this command will ensure that this file
really exists and if it doesn't exist it
will fail the job
so let's go ahead commit this and see
how the pipeline looks like
if we're looking at the pipeline
we'll notice
something unusual
and that is we're building the laptop
and at the same time we're testing it
and essentially what we wanted to do is
to have this in two separate stages
right we first build and then we test
now currently what we did is we assigned
by default both of these jobs to the
test stage they both are running in
parallel
but of course these are not the kind of
jobs that we can execute in parallel
because they depend on one another
particularly the test job depends on
first the build job completely so i'm
not even going to look at why the test
build failed because by the way this
pipeline looks like doesn't make a lot
of sense
and we have to go back to the concept of
stages
so what we want to do is to have two
different stages and we're going to
change our pipeline configuration and
define these stages we want to have a
build stage and we want to have a test
stage
in gitlab we can go ahead and define
another configuration which is called
stages
and here as a list we can define the
stages that we want to have so we can
see here we want to have the build stage
and we want to have the test stage
and in order to specify which job
belongs to which stage
in the job configuration we will also
say to which stage this job belongs so
for example we want the build laptop job
to belong to the build stage so i'm
going to write here stage
and the stage will be built
the same goes for the test laptop now if
you don't specify a stage here it will
automatically belong to the test stage
by default
but actually you want to make it as
explicit as possible so we're going to
write here
stage
test
so we here we have defined the stages we
have assigned the build laptop job to
the build stage
and we have assigned the test laptop job
to the test stage
so let's commit these changes and take a
look again at the pipeline
if we're looking at the pipeline we'll
be able to see now the two stages that
we have build and test so these stages
will run one after the other
this stage does not start until the
build stage is over so first we have to
build a laptop and then we can start
with a test
unfortunately this is still failing so
in this case we really have to take a
look inside this job and understand what
is going on
and we'll see here that the last command
that we have executed
is this test command here so up to this
point everything seems to be working
fine
this has been the last command that we
have executed
and somehow
this job has failed
in the next lecture we'll try to
understand why do pipelines fail
so let's jump into that and continue
debugging this problem
so let's try to understand why did this
job fail
looking here inside the job blocks
we'll be able to see here this error
says job failed
exit code 1.
exit codes are a way to communicate if
the execution of a program has been
successful or not
an exit code 0 will indicate that a
program has executed successfully
any other exit code which can be a
number from 1 to 255
will indicate failure
so in this case exit code 1 is not a 0
so it means something has failed
this exit code is issued by one of the
commands that we have in our script
as soon as one of these commands will
execute an exit code execution of the
job will stop
in this case we have only one command so
it's relatively easy to figure out which
command has issued this exit code most
likely it is the last command that you
see here inside the logs
so in this case what test is trying us
to tell is that
it has tested for the existence of this
file
and couldn't find it if the file would
have been there would have gotten an
exit code 0
and the execution would have continued
in this case the file is for some reason
not there and we have retrieved an exit
code 1. this tells gitlab that this job
has failed and then the entire execution
will stop
if a job in the pipeline fails
by default the entire pipeline will be
marked as failed as well
let me show you an example
let's go back to our pipeline definition
and we already know that the build
laptop job works just fine
so let's see here somewhere in the
middle we're going to add a new command
and this command will be the exit
command
and we're going to exit with the code
one
so what we should observe is that
commands echo make tier and touch are
still being executed
but for example here where we're putting
the main board
we're using cat and again we're putting
the keyboard
inside this file this shouldn't be
executed anymore
so now i've executed the pipeline again
you will see here that a build job
failed
and because this job failed the rest of
the pipeline was not executed so it was
interrupted as soon as something has
failed it actually doesn't really make a
lot of sense to continue with the rest
of the stages if one of the jobs before
has failed so let's go inside it and
take a look at the execution logs to see
what exactly has happened here
and you'll be able to see as i said we
have here the this echo command that's
being executed we have
created this directory we have created
this file and then we have exit one
and then we says here job failed exit
code one now we have forced this failure
here but i just wanted to demonstrate
like where in the execution you can
notice that something went wrong
and actually going through these
commands that are executed
looking at your job configuration trying
to figure out what has happened what is
the last command that did something
sometimes inside the logs you will find
hints in regards to what went wrong in
this case there are not a lot of hints
in terms of what went wrong but these
are also very simple commands but it's
very important to
read the logs from from the beginning
as high as possible to understand like
which docker image has been used what is
happening before are there maybe any any
warnings or any hints that something
went wrong this case that's not the case
and then to locate okay what was the
last command that i executed why did
this command fail
so i'm gonna remove this exit code and
we're gonna continue with the rest of
the course and try to understand how we
can get the simple pipeline to run
let's go back to our pipeline
configuration
and understand what are we doing wrong
as you probably remember from the
architecture discussion
every job runs independently
which means here the build laptop job
will start the docker container will
create this folder and this file will
put this text as instructed
and then at the end
we'll destroy the container meaning the
file that we had created inside this
docker container will be gone as well
and test laptop will start a completely
new container
that doesn't have this file there and
for that reason
it cannot pass
this test file will always tell us that
there is no file there because from
where could this file come
now does this mean that we can only use
a single job meaning that we need to
move this command here to test inside
the build laptop
well that would be very inconvenient
because then would have a big job that
does everything
and would kind of lose the overview of
what our pipeline steps really are
now there is a way to save the output of
the job
this case the output of the job what we
are actually interested in this job is
this file
including this folder
and gitlab has this concept of artifacts
now an artifact is essentially a job
output it's something that's coming out
of the job that we really want to save
it's not something that we want to throw
away for example we may have used any
other files or any other commands within
the job but we're only interested in the
final output that we have here
so in order to tell gitlab hey
i really want to keep this file in this
folder we need to define the artifacts
so the artifacts are an additional
configuration an additional keyword that
we add to our pipeline as the name tells
its artifacts
don't write it artifact because gitlab
will not recognize that
and as a property of artifacts we're
going to use paths
so notice it is indented it's not a list
and then below paths
we can add a folder or a file that we
want to save now in this case
we're going to tell gitlab save
everything that is inside this build
folder
so now let's give it a run and see how
the pipeline performs this time
now if we're looking at the pipeline
execution
we now see that both building the laptop
and testing the laptop
are successful
so what exactly has happened behind the
scenes did we reuse the same docker
container or what has happened there
well to understand exactly what has
happened and how these jobs now work we
have to go inside the logs
and we try to understand what exactly
did this build job do differently this
time
and what i want you to notice here is
that
towards the end if you compare it to the
logs of the previous job
we also have this indication that
something is happening and it will tell
you here uploading artifacts for a
successful job
and will tell you here which artifacts
are being uploaded we'll reference here
the build folder and says that two files
and directories were found
and
these are being uploaded to the
coordinator not a coordinator to put it
very simply essentially the gitlab
server so in this case
the runner has finished this job has
noticed inside the configuration oh i
need to do something with these files
and
we'll
essentially archive these files
and we'll give them back to the gitlab
server and tell them hey i'm finished
with this job i'm just going to destroy
this docker image
you wanted to keep these files so you
know here we go just
handle these files i'm i'm done with my
job here so essentially the runner is
not saving these files they're being
saved somewhere else in the storage
now when the next job is being executed
something pretty similar is happening
i'm gonna go here to the test laptop job
and what you see here in the beginning
there's also a new indication inside the
logs that something different is
happening
and we'll see here downloading artifacts
and
says again downloading artifacts from
coordinator
which essentially means we now are
downloading this build folder inside the
new docker container that we have just
created
we have managed to copy this files from
one job to the next one
and this is why now this test command is
able to find the build folder and the
computer.txt file inside it
and the job is passing
if this job is still failing for some
reason it's always a good idea to take a
look at the job that has generated the
artifacts
so in order to do that again we're going
to go and visit the pipeline
and if we go inside the build laptop job
here on the right hand side
you should see some information in
regards to the job artifacts
and
in order for these job artifacts to
exist they are saved even after the job
has terminated and you have the
possibility of inspecting them so if
you're not really sure like what is the
contents of the file you don't really
need to go inside
the build pipeline and make some
debugging there you could do that but
essentially what has been saved here is
the final version of the artifacts that
are being used so you can go here inside
browse
you'll find here the build folder that
we have specified
and we'll find here the computer.txt
and of course you can download this file
and you can take a look at it after you
download it on your computer and see if
it has the right content
make sure that when you're testing this
you're actually giving the correct path
and not some other path
that's a very important way on how you
can actually inspect the outputs of the
job
at this point i wouldn't say that we are
really done with testing the build
output
yes this file exists and we have now
tested it so this is a very basic test
that we have written here
but how about checking the contents of
the file to see if it contains the main
board and the keyboard as we expect
again just using a command like cat and
displaying this into logs doesn't really
help us automate this we need a tool
that when it doesn't find the respective
text in the file it will issue an exit
code and tell us that that text is not
really present there
and for that purpose we're going to use
the grep command
so this is the grep command
and grep is a cli tool that allows us to
search for a specific string in a file
so we're going to specify here for
example the string to be mainboard i'm
going to copy it from above just to make
sure i don't make any mistakes there
and we also can specify in which file
we're looking for this so we know that
this file already exists so
this is an additional test here that
we're adding on top of this
and now we actually know that the file
exists but now we want to check if this
word main board is inside the file
and of course we can also duplicate this
and write an additional
test here gonna check for the keyboard
as well we're checking for the main
board and the keyboard
now grep is really complex command and
can support regular expressions and many
other advanced features
but i won't get into those i'm gonna
commit these changes and in a few
seconds take a look at the pipeline
all right so now if we're taking a look
at the pipeline we'll see the build job
is still successful the test job is
still successful
so if we're looking inside here
what we'll be able to see we'll be able
to see some log outputs
and then
grab here is looking for the word main
board inside this file and is able to
find it will be displayed here and it's
also looking for the word keyboard
inside this file and is able to find it
what's important about writing tests is
to also ensure that your pipeline will
fail if one of these tests doesn't work
and sometimes you may think that the
command does what it's supposed to do
but the best way to make sure that
you're really mastering that command to
actually introduce an error inside your
build job essentially and to check if
the test job will fail so let's go ahead
and try that out
so here inside our build job what can we
do well for example we could
try and make a change here for example
i'm going to remove the m from main
board
and i'm gonna simply
commit these changes and to see if this
job is now failing
we've been looking now inside the tests
we'll be able to see here that the last
command that was executed was grep you
will see it in comparison to the
previous one there's no text being
outputted below this is the last command
that was executed we're getting an exit
code 1 which essentially means grep has
looked inside this file couldn't find
the word main board
so let's go back and fix our pipeline
but this has been a very important test
because if you're not really checking
that our pipeline will fail at one point
then whatever we did inside the pipeline
in terms of testing is really not very
useful
i'm going to go and add here main board
back to the configuration
and
as we expect now in the pipeline will
also work again
tests also play a very particular role
when we're working on this pipeline when
we're building software
there are many various levels of testing
but essentially tests allow us to make
changes to our software or to our build
process
and to ensure that everything works the
same
for example i heard that
if we are using this operator here and
we're putting text inside a file
that this approach doesn't really
require to have the file already created
with the touch command
so how about we try this out and see if
we can rely on the tests to get this to
work so i'm going to simply remove this
touch command
and i'm going to commit a configuration
we'll see what's going on
so let's take a look at the pipeline
and what do we see
this test job is successful
and if we really want to manually check
once again we can go to the build laptop
job
we can take a look at the artifacts
we'll see the build folder is there
the computer.txt file is there
so apparently
we didn't need to have this touch
command in our configuration
and by having the tests we have gained
an additional level of confidence that
whatever changes we're making we kind of
trust the tests and if the pipeline is
passing we know that in the end we'll
have this computer.txt file and i will
have the proper content
let's take another look at our pipeline
configuration
what if we need to change the name of
the file so so far we have used this
name computer.txt
but what if we need to call it for
example laptop.txt
now quite often we don't really like
when we have something for example a
file name or something that could change
and have that spread out to the entire
pipeline because if we need to make a
change we need to identify all the
currencies now this is a very simple
example and it is relatively easy to
identify this
but quite often for example going into a
large file and doing something like a
replace all can lead to some undesirable
errors that could occur
so quite often when we have something
that we are essentially multiple times
inside a file inside the configuration
we want to put that into a variable
and that way if it's inside a variable
if we need to make changes to that
particular value we only have to change
it once and then it would be replaced
all over
so how do we define a variable well we
can
go inside our script block and define a
variable here so for example you can
just define a variable called build file
name
and we see i'm writing this in lowercase
and we have also some underscores to
separate the words
and then we can use the equal sign and
write something like laptop.txt
now in order to reference this variable
we're going to copy the name and
go whenever we need to
have this and we're going to start with
the dollar sign and then the variable
name so we're referencing the variable
by using the dollar sign before the
variable name
now this is a local variable that is
available only inside this script and it
will only be available inside this job
so for this job we'll need to do the
same thing as well
as you've noticed quite often we write
local variables in lowercase and using
lowercase helps avoid any conflicts with
any other existing variables
now this is one way how we can do this
but there's also the possibility of
defining a variable block we can go
inside the configuration of the job and
write something like
variables this will not be a list that's
very important so
this will be
build
file name
column
and the value will be laptop.txt
so this is essentially almost the same
as writing it like this
but we are getting it away from the
script and we are letting gitlab do this
for us
and of course if we need to do this we
have to take it from here and also put
this in the other job
so we'll have some duplication here in
terms of the configuration
we can also define a global variable
which is available for all jobs in order
to define something globally all we have
to do is take it from here
and due to the indentation we're going
to move it outside of the job
and everything that's happening here is
on a global level so i'm gonna
move it here at the root of this
document essentially
here we define variables
and this is the name and whenever we
have this we have to use this syntax
and of course we can go ahead and remove
it from the test job because it would
also be available there
now this is essentially as defining an
environment variable
which is available for the entire system
while there is no hard rule we typically
write environment variables in all caps
and still use underscores to separate
the words
because we are inside an ide i'm going
to select this text
use the f1 command
and then i'm going to transform to
uppercase
so this is how i want it to look like
build file
name and wherever i want to have this
again dollar sign
and this name so for example i'm going
to have it here for computer as well
here this command which we may decide to
replace or not really depends on us but
i'm going to replace it here as well
i'm going to use it here
and here
and here
so again wherever we had computer.txt
we have now replaced this with this
environment variable and whenever we
need to make changes to it we can easily
just change it here it's pretty easy to
see
maybe adding some other variables that
we have inside our pipelines
it will make the managing of these
details much easier
well in this example it is not necessary
depending on which characters you
include in your variable value you may
need to put everything between quotes
this is just something to keep in mind
but this is a very simple text here that
we have
so
that will not cause any conflicts in
general with the yaml syntax so let's
commit these changes and see if the
pipeline is still working as it should
the pipeline is running successfully and
we can go inside the build
job that we had here and we can take a
look at the artifacts
and indeed we'll see that now we are
using this file name laptop.txt and no
longer
computer.txt so i have mentioned devops
quite a few times and by now you have
heard of devops as well
so what is devops
let me tell you first what devops is not
devops is not a standard or a
specification
different organizations may have a
different understanding of devops
devops is not a tool or a particular
software
nor is it something you do if you use a
particular tool or a set of tools
devops is a cultural thing
it represents a change in mindset
let's take a look at the following
example
you have a customer who wants a new
feature a business person let's call
them a project manager would try to
understand what the customer wants
write some specifications and hand them
over to the developers
the developers will build this feature
pass it on to the testers who would test
it
once ready the project manager would
review the work and if all looks good
would ask the developers to pass the
software package to the sysadmins to
deploy it
as you can see there's a lot of passing
stuff around and in the end if something
goes wrong and often things go wrong in
such situations
everyone is unhappy
and everyone else is to blame
so why does it happen
because every group has a different
perspective on the work
there is no real collaboration and
understanding between these groups
let's zoom in on the relation between
the developers and the sys admins the
developers are responsible for building
software
ensuring that all these cool features
that the customers want make it into the
product
the it operations team is responsible
for building and maintaining the it
infrastructure ensuring the i.t systems
run smoothly securely and with as little
downtime as possible
do these groups have something in common
yes of course the software the product
the problem is the idea operation team
knows very little about the software
they need to operate
and the developers know very little
about the infrastructure where the
software is running so devops is a set
of practices that tries to address this
problem but to say that devops is just a
combination of development and operation
would be an understatement
actually everyone mentioned before works
on the software just in a different
capacity
since the final outcome impacts everyone
it makes sense for all these groups to
collaborate
the cultural shift that devops brings is
also tightly connected to the agile
movement
in an ever more complex environment
where business conditions and
requirements change all the time
and where we need to juggle tons of
tools and technologies every day
the best culture is not one of blaming
and finger pointing
but one of experimentation and learning
from past mistakes
so we want to have everyone collaborate
instead of working in silos and stages
instead of finger pointing everyone
takes responsibility for the final
outcome
if the final product works
and the customers or users of the
product are happy
everyone wins
the customers the project managers the
developers the testers the sysadmins and
anyone else i did not mention everyone
wins
however devops is more than just culture
to succeed organizations adopting devops
also focus on automating their tasks
manual and repetitive work is a
productivity killer
and this is what we are going to address
in this course
automatically building and deploying
software which falls under a practice
called ci cd
we want to automate as much as possible
to save time and give us the chance to
put that time to good use instead of
manually repeating the same tasks over
and over again
but to automate things we need to get
good at using the shell working with cli
tools reading documentation writing
scripts
quite often you may see devops being
represented by this image
while this does not give a complete
picture of what devops really is
it does show a series of steps a typical
software product goes through
from planning
all the way to operating and monitoring
the most important thing i want you to
notice in this representation is that
this process never stops it goes on and
on in an endless loop
this means that we continue going
through these steps with each iteration
or new version of the software
what is not represented here is the
feedback that goes back into the product
devops goes hand in hand with the agile
movement
if adrian and scrum are new to you
make sure to add this to your to-do list
nowadays many organizations go through
an agile transformation and value
individuals who know what agile and
scrum are
regardless of the role
i've added some resources you may want
to look into in the course notes
if you have some free time while
commuting or doing other things around
your house
i highly recommend you listen to the
phoenix project as an audiobook
it is an accurate description of what
companies that are not adopting devops
go on a day-to-day basis and
realistically portrays such a transition
this is by no means a technical book and
i'm sure it will be a fun lesson
so devops is a set of practices that
helps us build successful products
to do that we need a shift in thinking
and new tools that support automation
however i must warn you that you can use
tools that have devops written all over
them and still not do devops so devops
is so much more than just adopting a
particular tool with that being said
let's continue diving into gitlab ci
in this unit we will start working on a
simple project we want to automate any
of the manual steps required for
integrating the changes of multiple
developers and create a pipeline that
will build and test the software we are
creating in other words we will do
continuous integration continuous
integration is a practice and the first
step when doing devops
usually we're not the only ones working
on a project and when we're doing
continuous integration we're integrating
our code with the code other developers
created it means that every time we make
changes to the code that code is being
tested and integrated with the work
someone else did
it is called continuous integration
because we integrate work continuously
as it happens we don't wait for anything
to do that we don't want to integrate
work once per week or once per month as
it can already be too late or too costly
to resolve some issues the more we wait
the higher the chances we will run into
integration issues in this unit we will
use gitlab to verify any changes and
integrate them in the project i'm going
to be honest with you as we build more
advanced pipelines you will most likely
encounter some issues if you haven't
done it yet go right now to the video
description and open the course notes
there you will find important resources
and troubleshooting tips
finally let's do a quick recap when we
have multiple developers working against
the same code repository ci is a
pipeline that allows us to add and
integrate our changes even multiple
times per day what comes out is a new
version of the product if you're still
unsure about continuous integration at
this point don't worry we'll implement
ci in our development process in the
upcoming lessons
for the rest of the course we'll be
using this project this is a simple
website built with react which is a
javascript technology developed by
facebook now we don't want to get too
much into the technical details because
they don't really matter so much at this
point
but the first step in order to be able
to make changes to this repository is to
make a copy of it so for example if
you're trying here to open a web ide in
this project
i will get this option to fork the
project by the way you will find a link
to this project in the course notes and
the course notes are linked in the video
description
so
we can click here on fork
and we'll make a copy of this project
under our account
now that we made a copy out of this
project we can then open the web ide and
start making changes to it and
particularly what we're trying to do is
to create the pipeline so let me give
you an overview of the tasks that we are
trying to automate
essentially here in this project we have
a couple of files one of these files is
this package.json file
and this file essentially documents
which requirements this project has and
in order to actually run this project we
first need to install these requirements
so locally i already have a copy of this
project and the command to install these
requirements is called yarn
install
so now all the requirements have been
installed
the next step would be to create a build
and that would be done using the command
yarn build
and during this process what has
actually happened is that a build folder
has been created and this build folder
contains multiple files that are
required for the website so let me give
you an idea how this website looks like
and what we actually did here so i'm
going to run the command serve minus s
and going to specify the build folder
and now essentially we have started a
server we started an http server which
is serving the files available there so
i'm going to open this address in a new
tab
and this is how the website looks like
so essentially what we're trying to do
in this section is to automate these
steps so we want to install the
dependencies we want to create a build
we want to test the bill to see if the
website is working
and i've shown you these tools because
it is always a good idea to be familiar
with the cli tools that we will be using
in gitlab ci
now in gitlab we try to automate any
manual steps but before we do that we
must know and understand these steps we
cannot jump into automation before we
understand what the commands that we
want to do are actually doing
now i'm not really referring in
particular to the commands that i've
shown you here
because they are specific to this
project you may be using python or java
or anything else
so you don't need to be familiar with
these tools in particular i will explain
to you what they do and how they work
however what is important to understand
is the concepts the concepts remain the
same and this is what we are actually
focusing on in this course we are
focusing on understanding the concepts
around automation
so let's begin creating the ci pipeline
for this project so i'm gonna go ahead
and create here a new file
and of course the definition file for
the pipeline will be
dot
gitlab.ci dot yaml
the first job that we want to add here
is build website
and
what we are trying to do here where
we're trying to build this website and
why do we need to build the website well
essentially or most software projects do
have a build step
in this case we're essentially creating
some production files production ready
files which are smaller optimized for
production from some source files so we
have here in the source files
you will see here an app.js and any
other file so essentially the build
process will take all these files and
we'll make them smaller and we'll put
them together in a way
other programming languages may need to
have a compilation step or any other
steps so typically something happens in
the build process where we actually are
putting our project together
now of course we don't want to do that
manually from our computer we want to
let gitlab do this for us
so let's go ahead and write here the
script for this
the first step is
to
essentially run
yarn and yarn is a tool that is helping
us build this project and this is
specific for
javascript projects essentially node.js
projects and yarn is a tool that can be
used for getting dependencies they can
also be used for building the software
so the command that we are running here
is build
locally as you remember the first thing
that i did was to do a yarn install to
install dependencies and this is
something that needs to happen before
the build so every time
when we are building this website we
need to get the dependencies to make
sure that we have all the dependencies
that we need and to ensure that all of
them are up to date and because they
don't remain anywhere in the container
we need to do that all the time normally
locally would do that only when we need
to do that
so for example when we know that we need
a newer dependency of a software package
but gitlab doesn't have this information
so we kind of like need to run this all
the time
you also need to specify your docker
image so let's try for example
alpine which we have used before
so essentially what i'm trying to do is
to replicate the commands that i've
executed on my computer
installing dependencies and building the
project
so let's commit these changes and see
what pipeline does i'm going to commit
them to the main branch and click on
commit here
you can take a look at what the job is
doing
and we'll be able to see here that we
get an exit code now remember any exit
code that is not zero
will lead to a job failure and it says
here job failed now why did this job
fail
well we have to look like what is the
command that we try to execute
and we'll find here
something saying that yarn not found
so essentially what this means is that
the docker image that we have used does
not have yarn
so how do we
install yarn or how do we normally do
this
now the thing is we don't have to use
this alpine image that you have seen
here
essentially for
most projects and this includes node.js
which is actually what we're using here
and which i already have installed
locally and this is why it worked
locally
there are official docker images that we
can use
and
the central repository for such images
is docker hub so this is a public docker
repository so for example if i'm typing
here node
i will be able to find here the official
image for node
and i can essentially instead of using
alpine i can simply use here node
so let me go back to the project
and i'm going to write here node
now the thing is when we're doing here
when you're writing alpine or node
what is actually happening is that we
are always getting the latest version of
that docker image
sometimes it may work but sometimes the
latest version may contain some breaking
changes which may lead to things not
working anymore in our pipeline if one
day we're getting one version and the
next day we're getting something else
without us making any changes
things may break
so for that reason it is generally not a
good idea to just use node for example
or just to use alpine as we have done
before it is better to specify a version
to put it down like which version do we
need here and to write it down as
essentially as a tag
now how do we know which version do we
need now for node what we're going to do
here we're going to head to nodejs.org
and here you'll see here two versions
that are currently available for
download
what we wanna do is we wanna use the lts
version now you will see here that the
latest lts version that i'm currently
seeing right now is 16.13.2
now what's important here is the major
version which is 16.
when you're watching this it's important
that you come to this page and you look
at a number here probably it will
increase over time most likely it will
increase over time
you'll get a different version it's
important here that you get
the latest lts version that you see here
all right so let's go inside our
pipeline and then write this 16 version
here so the way we're going to do here
we have node which is the base image and
then we can specify a tag by writing
column
and then i'm going to write 16
right
and most likely this version is already
available on node but you can always
make sure and check here go to the tags
and see if this specific tag is then
available there but this major tags
typically they are available and
will have no issues downloading this
so let's commit the changes and see how
it goes and again i'm gonna push to the
main branch
when it's executing you will be able to
see here which image is being downloaded
and you will see here it's node and the
tag is for the version 16.
now this job is now requiring much much
longer to run you will see here the
duration in this case was one minute and
35 seconds
and this is because
we have to download what is a relatively
large docker image this node
image
and then we are installing the
dependencies
and you'll see here that these
dependencies take 44 seconds to be
installed to figure out which
dependencies are required to download
them from the internet that takes a bit
and then
we are actually doing the build
and this also takes a few seconds to
complete
but fortunately everything is then
successful in the end and this is the
most important step at this point
we don't want to waste a lot of time
when we are actually executing these
builds and i know for a fact that this
note image is a few hundred megabytes
large in size
this is because it contains a lot of
tools and a lot of dependencies which we
may not need
so for that reason it's always a good
idea for these larger images to go here
on the specific image to click here on
the tags tab
and generally to take a look at like
what is the size of these images and
what's happening with them because some
of them are quite big
so we could theoretically search here
for version 16.
and by default
we can see here that this is the one tag
that's more specific it's not exactly
what we're using we will see here
version 16 something
it has about
332
megabytes
so if we're selecting to use this image
every time we'll have to download 300
something megabytes that's a lot of
download and a lot of time that we are
wasting just to start this image
so for that reason uh what i typically
do is i go here in the tags and i search
for alpine sometimes slim or other
images can also be a good idea and what
i'm interested in is something like 16
alpine so let me
write directly 16 alpine
and
this looks absolutely fine here
so 16 will be again the node
version that we are trying to use and if
we're looking here at the size
take a look at this it's 38 megabytes
so what we're going to do we're going to
simply take this
and go in our pipeline and replace
16 with this tag
so here inside instead of using 16 we're
going to use 16-alpine
gonna commit these changes we're gonna
take a look again at the pipeline to see
how long does it take right now
to build this
so this job still needed quite a bit of
time one minute and 26 seconds
you may see this duration varying but
generally it is a very good practice to
use images that are as small as possible
because this can save time and you may
see that maybe this job will even go
below one minute it really depends like
how fast the
runner will pick up the job and will
able to start this image
but the main idea is the same we now
have managed to automate the first steps
in our project we're installing some
dependencies
and then we are running the build
so
this seems to be working just fine
just to recap we are using this node
image before we have tried using alpine
image
now the alpine image didn't work because
it didn't have node js installed now
essentially what we're using here is
essentially the same image as before the
same alpine image alpine linux image
but it has node installed so it has the
dependency that we need and this node
dependency contains yarn this is why
yarn didn't work before
now it's working just fine and it's
building the project
the most important thing that you can do
when you're learning something new is
practicing
and i want to give you the opportunity
in this course to practice along so not
just following along what i'm doing but
to also have the opportunity to do
something on your own
and for the next assignment i already
think that you have to know how
necessary in order to do that
what we're trying to do is to create two
new additional jobs in this pipeline
this is your job now to write these jobs
so what are these jobs all about the
first job is trying to test the website
and the website is currently inside the
build folders if i go inside the build
folder
you will see here a list of files
now your job is to ensure that the
index.html file is available inside the
build folder so this is the first job
that you need to create the second job i
want you to create is in regards to
running units so in order to run unit
tests the command that we are using is
yarn
test
and the only thing you need to do is to
create a job and to run this command to
take a look at the logs and see that the
tests have indeed been executed
the upcoming lesson will contain the
solution to this
but please it's super important that you
pause this video and try this on your
own try as much as you can because this
is the best way to learn and to ensure
that what i'm showing you in this course
is something that you will be able to
use in your projects as well
i hope you have tried to solve this
assignment on your own
but anyway this is how i would approach
this problem so i'm here inside the
editor for the pipeline and let's begin
just with the skeleton so what are we
trying to do we have two new jobs we
have test website
where are we essentially trying to test
the output of the build website job
and we also have a unit tests job
so first of all we have to think about
stages
what we want to do happens essentially
after the build
well it really depends a bit so for
example the test website this definitely
needs to happen after the build
the unit tests they don't necessarily
need to happen after the build
but we're going to put them inside
a different stage as well so let's go
ahead and define the stages here so
we're going to have two stages we're
going to have here built
and we're going to have another stage
which is called test
and what we need to do is to assign this
jobs to a stage so the build will be
assigned to the stage
built of course
and then the test
website will be assigned to the stage
test
and the same goes with the unit test
right in order to test the website what
we are trying to do well let's try and
write the script we are trying to test
if we have an index.html
file there so as you probably remember
the command test
dash
f
so this we are testing for the existing
solar file
this needs to be inside the build folder
and the name of the file is index.html
now what we haven't done so far is
inside this build website job to declare
artifacts
so as it is right now this command will
fail
so what we have to do here is of course
think about the artifacts so which
artifacts do you have we have to define
the paths
and the only paths that we're interested
in is the build path
so then this will be able
to test for this file
the next thing we need to think about is
which image do we need for test website
so theoretically we could use node 16
but actually this command test doesn't
require something like that so we could
just use alpine
and test is a pretty general command so
we don't have to worry about specifying
a version or anything like that
so just going with alpine should be just
fine
there's of the unit test we essentially
need this node image because we'll be
using yarn so i'm going to simply go
ahead and
copy this
image that we have used in the build
website
and of course the script will also be
kind of a similar
uh we still need to install dependencies
so yarn install is necessary here when
we're trying to run the unit test and
the command that we want to run is yarn
test
so let's double check to make sure that
we have everything in place we have
defined two stages build and test we
have assigned build website to the stage
build and we have assigned
the test website and the unit tests we
have assigned them both to the stage
test so this means these two jobs will
run in parallel
here we're just using the test command
to verify if this file exists
and here we're installing the
dependencies and then running the tests
so i'm going to go ahead
commit these changes and we'll inspect
together the pipeline
and after a minute or two this buy plan
will succeed and you'll notice here the
two stages build and test we're building
a website and then we're testing what we
have
the unit tests are not necessarily
dependent on the build itself but we put
them together in a test
so if looking here at test website what
do we see well we see here the command
test minus f so it's testing if this
file actually exists if it's part of the
job artifacts of course if you're
looking inside the build website
you can go here and look at the
artifacts
see here the build folder
we'll see here multiple files so not
only the index.html file but we'll see
here some images some additional files
that we don't really care so much at
this point but they are available there
so that's the most important aspect that
we really care about
and here the unit tests
the unit tests are part of the project
and generally when writing code we are
also writing unit tests to document that
what we're doing there is working
properly
you will see here the command that has
triggered the test has been yarn test
there's only one
file here that contains only one test
all these tests have been executed
and because the tests are passing the
job is also succeeding any of these
tests would not work then the job will
be failing and the entire pipeline will
also be failing
the first tool we need for integrating
work is already in place
we are using git for versioning our code
we also use gitlab as a central git
repository
we take git for granting nowadays but it
solves a critical issue and is one of
the first devops tools you need to know
while this course does not go into git i
highly recommend checking the course
notes for a comprehensive git tutorial
so in our current model every developer
pushes changes to the main branch
whatever version of code has been pushed
last time in the main branch that is the
latest version
anyone wanting to add new changes will
have to make them compatible with the
main branch
however this model does have a serious
flaw nothing is safeguarding the main
branch
what if the latest changed has
introduced an issue and we can't build a
project anymore
or what if the tests are failing
this is now a massive problem as nobody
on the team can continue working and we
can't deliver new versions of the
software
a broken main branch is like when the
production halts in a factory
is not good for
business we must ensure that the main
branch does not contain any broken code
the main branch should always work and
allow us to deliver new versions of the
software anytime we need to do that
so how do we solve this
the idea is simple we just don't push
untested work in the main branch
since we can't trust that developers
remember to run all tests locally before
pushing a change
we want to take advantage of automation
and gitlab to automatically run the
tests before adding any changes to the
main branch
the idea is to work with other branches
which are later integrated into the main
branch
this way every developer can work
independently of other developers
there are various git workflows but we
will use one that is simple to
understand
it's called the git feature branch
workflow
the idea is simple for each new feature
bug idea experiment or change we want to
make we create a new branch
we push our changes there
let the pipeline run on the branch and
if everything seems okay we can
integrate the changes in the main branch
so in other words we simulate running
the main branch before we actually run
the main branch
if our branch pipeline fails no worries
all other developers are unaffected and
we can focus on fixing it or if we don't
like how things turned out we can just
abandon the branch and delete it no hard
feelings there either
as part of working with branches we
create a merge request that allows other
developers to review our code before it
gets merged
a merge request is essentially one
developer asking for the changes to be
added to the main branch the changes are
reviewed and if nobody has objections we
can merge them
so this is the plan for the upcoming
lessons to start working with git
branches and merge requests so let's get
to work
so how can we create merge requests in
gitlab
first of all to ensure that the chances
of breaking the main branch are as small
as possible
we need to tweak a few settings
so we're going to go here to settings
general
and right here in the middle you should
see merge requests i'm going to expand
that
and what i like to use when using merge
requests is to use this fast forward
merge essentially no merge commits are
created and generally the history
remains much cleaner
there's also the possibility of
squashing commits directly from gitlab
and you can put it here and encourage
scratching commits is when you're
pushing multiple changes to a branch
and instead of pushing all these changes
back into the main branch we scratch
them all together so we essentially like
we have only one commit again makes the
history much easier to read going
forward here in the merge checks want to
make sure that the pi appliance succeed
before we are merging something so this
is a super important setting here that
we have
so let's go ahead here go at the bottom
and click on save changes
and additionally again from settings
we're going to go here to repository
and from the repository you're going to
go here to protected branches i'm going
to expand this
and what we want to do here is we want
to protect the main branch
so essentially we don't want to commit
changes to the main branch anymore we
want to prohibit that so nobody will be
allowed to directly commit something to
the main branch so in order to do that
we have to go here to allow to push
and instead of having something selected
or some role selected here can i use no
one so no one is allowed to push to this
protected branch only if it goes through
a merge request
so these are the initial settings that
we need to do
and we'll be able to see here now let's
try and make some changes and open the
web ide
open the pipeline file
and now let's say i'm trying to add here
a new stage where i'm trying to do some
checks for example there is linter that
i can use
and linter is simply a static code
analyzes tool that is used to identify
potential programming errors stylistic
issues
and sometimes you know questionable code
constructs since it is static it does
not actually run the application it just
looks at the source code
and most projects do tend to have such
linter inside
and just for the sake of completion i
also want to add here linter
so i'm gonna go ahead here and i'm gonna
write here linter this is the
name of the job
the image that i'm using is still node
here
and the reason for that is inside the
script
the command that we are running is
actually yarn
lint
and of course we also need to install
all dependencies
and additionally we have the possibility
of assigning this job
to a stage
now by default gitlab comes with some
predefined stages
prefix stages include a press stage
build stage a test stage a deploy stage
and a post stage
so these are all actually predefined and
to be honest this is just to make it
clear like which stages we are defining
here and which stages we are using
but these are already defined by gitlab
so we're just essentially redefining
something that exists
so for this linter i could
go ahead and use a stage and this stage
name will be dot pre
and this linter has absolutely no
dependencies on the build itself
the same goes for example here with the
unit tests
the unit tests are also not dependent on
the build so i could go ahead and move
them to the same stage
just to make this clear so there's a dot
there and because this is a predefined
stage we don't need to redefine it again
so i could go ahead and write it here
but it's not really needed all right
now going back here
the editor that i opened here is from
the main branch you will see here main
is selected right
and let's go ahead and commit
and you'll see here
i'm no longer allowed
to commit to the main branch so this is
by default
the settings that we did ensure that we
are no longer allowed to directly make
changes to the main branch so we have to
create a new branch quite often
when we are creating branches we tend to
use some naming conventions now totally
up to you what you want to use or how
your organization
uses that
quite often you will have something like
feature for example forward slash and
then a name of a feature
sometimes you may reference a ticket or
something like that so for example you
have your ticket number one two three
four
add linter
so you will see here i'm adding no
spaces or anything like that
it's totally up to you how you use these
forward slashes hyphens as separators
and so on you'll also see here the
possibility of starting a new merge
request so
i'm essentially these changes now are
not committed i'm going to create a new
branch the branch name will be feature
forward slash and some name
i'm going to click here on commit
this will open an additional window so
the branch has been created
but now i'm also opening a new merge
request
and here in the merge request there are
a few things that i should fill out so
for example
the title is not very suggestive so i'm
gonna write here something like
add
linter to the project
you can also go ahead and provide a
description
this is also useful for the people who
are looking at this much request to know
why
this is important what this feature is
bringing or if it is a bug fix which
issues is this fixing and so on so you
could do that
there are also some additional labels
and options that you can set here
i'm not going to go over them because
they are essentially
relatively easy to explain
and i'm gonna go here and
click on create merge request
and now a new merge request has been
created
and
additionally we also have here a
pipeline that is running against this
branch
so what is happening here is that the
changes that we made
which you will be able to see here what
we do do we added here a new stage we
added here a linter uh also made some
changes to the do the unit test so we
can go ahead and
look at these changes we have here a
pipeline that's executing it's going
through all these stages we have here
the pre-stage
the build stage and the test stage
and now we can simulate running this
pipeline
to see if it fails if it fails we have
the opportunity or of fixing things if
it doesn't fail then we have the option
of merging these changes
the next important step in the life of a
merge request is the review process
especially the code review where
somebody else from the team is taking a
look at our changes
and is giving us feedback
now just in case you don't know where
your merge request is you will find here
on the left hand side this panel says
here merge requests and will indicate
how many merge requests are open at this
time so we only have one merge request
you will see here this is the title of
the merge request
so we're trying to add linter
and you'll find here like the most
important information so this is a
request to merge this feature into the
main branch right
if you need to make changes to it you
can open this branch in the id
and continue making changes to it
you have your information about the
pipeline so we know that the pipeline
has passed
and someone else looking at this we'll
be able to see here which commits have
been made
and also to have an overview of the
changes
inside here there are different views
that you can have
you can compare these files and someone
can
also leave comments here for example i
could simply click here on the line
and ask
why did you use
the prestage
right and can add a comment
now where does this merge request go now
typically
when someone has reviewed this can go
ahead here and approve it so you will
see here who has reviewed these changes
and you may have internal
roles like you need to people to review
any changes before they are being merged
so the changes can be approved and then
they can be merged
comments can appear so for example here
i've added a question to these changes
so maybe there's some discussion that
needs to happen there
feedback can be gathered from different
people involved
and this feedback may need to be
integrated so for example as i mentioned
you can still do changes to this the
much request will always have the latest
changes so we can make more commits
it's also possible that for some reason
these changes are no longer needed they
are
wrong or the approach that was taken
doesn't really make sense so so there's
also the possibility of closing a merge
request you can go here and see close
merge request so this will be closed and
no changes will be merged so that's also
a possibility
but
typically what happens after the review
after some changes have been integrated
we're gonna go here on this merge button
and what is happening here is
we are merging this branch
into the main branch
and there are two options that are
enabled by default
the source branch so the branch that we
have created will be deleted which makes
sense because we don't need it anymore
and in case we have multiple commits we
can also squash those commits and in
this case we have only one commit we can
modify the commit message if we want to
in this case that's not needed
and then we can simply click here on the
merge button
this merge button is available only if
the pipeline succeeded but our pipeline
did succeed so this is why we can see it
so now gitlab will merge these changes
into the main branch
and again a new pipeline will be
generated
and this is the pipeline for the main
branch so you will see exactly
the changes that we made
we have here the pre-stage the build and
the test
these are all available here
and exactly what we have run inside a
merge request the pipeline is running
again against the main branch
this is needed just to ensure that
indeed everything is working fine and
that there are no integration issues or
no other issues so it's a good practice
not something that
may seem that it's happening somehow
as a duplicate it's actually important
to ensure that the main pipeline is
working properly this is what we care
most about to ensure that this main
pipeline
is working as it should work that's the
reason why we have reviewed a merge
request to ensure that whatever we're
changing here in the main branch is as
good as it gets and that the chances of
breaking something
are drastically reduced
right in the beginning of this section
i'll show you locally which are the
steps they need to build this project
but i've also taken the build folder and
i've opened the website and you have
seen something that looks like this
how can we replicate this in gitlab
essentially we want to make sure that we
indeed have a website that's running
that can be started by a server
and we want to make sure that you know
for example this text here shows up
learn gitlab ci how can we do that
inside the pipeline currently we're just
checking if we have a file which is
called index.html
that's not really telling us the entire
story so this lecture we're going to
take a look at how we can do essentially
what's sometimes called an integration
test we're really testing that the final
product is really working
i'm going to open up the web ide
and inside the pipeline file kind of
focus on this test website job
so this current test is not really that
helpful we want to do something else so
for example
you have seen me running the following
command which has been serve
dash s build
right
so
this takes the build
and we'll be able to start a server and
then we can take a look at what's going
on
so we're going to remove this because we
don't need that anymore
i'm going to start here server
and just because i want to make sure
that this is running as fast as possible
and that we're not wasting a lot of time
i'm going to go ahead and disable some
jobs so i'm going to disable here the
linter job that's not really needed in
the beginning i'm going to also disable
the unit test so to disable the job you
simply add a dot in front of the job
name and that job will be disabled
let's go ahead and commit these changes
and again we'll have to create a new
branch
call this feature integration test
i'm going to start a new merge request
as well
i'm going to call it add integration
tests
i'm going to click here on create merge
request
if you're looking at the pipeline we'll
see that the build has succeeded
but there seems to be an issue
with testing the website so let's take a
look at the logs and understand what is
going on
we'll try to understand here what is the
error we're getting an exit code
the last command that we executed is
serv
and we're getting here surf not found so
again we're trying to
run a command
this command was working locally for me
but at least the docker image that we
are using here does not have this
command so which docker image are we
using we're using alpine
and alpine does not have this command so
we need to find a way to install this
command as well
so for that we're going to go back to
the editor uh we can
go here from the merge requests
click on the merge request
and we'll find here open in web ide
and then we'll be able to see here this
is essentially a list of changes that we
have this is the review it shows us what
we have changed but if you want to make
changes to the code
we're going to go here this will allow
us again to select the pipeline file and
make changes to it
so let's see what we need to do in order
to get this job to run as well now first
of all we're gonna use here this same
node image
because serve is actually
something that runs on node so it's a
dependency that runs on node
and we're gonna use yarn
and we're gonna add this dependency
i'm gonna see here yarn add serve
actually you're gonna use this as a
global dependency so i'm gonna write
here global
so using yarn global add serve
right this will ensure
that we now have serve we can use yarn
because we now have the node image
again this time we are already in a
merge request so we can go ahead click
on commit
i'm gonna commit directly here to the
existing branch that we have
and the pipeline will be executed again
be sure to watch what i'm explaining
next because we have introduced an issue
in this pipeline
and it's a big issue
but can explain in a second what that
issue is
i'm going to go ahead open this pipeline
and i'm going to go directly to this
test job
and wait a bit here to see
what is happening and wait for this job
to start
so i want you to notice what is
happening with this job
so we have started this docker
container which contains node
then we have added this dependency which
is serve
and then we have executed serv
which folder reserving or serving the
build folder
then it says here info accepting
connections on localhost port 3000.
so what is going on
well
we have started an http server which is
serving these files inside this gitlab
job and when does a server end
well it never ends that's the purpose of
the server it will serve these files
indefinitely
and of course this approach that we
started here is not good because
we're gonna wait here forever
well actually not forever jobs do have
a specific timeout you will see here the
timeout that is one hour
so if we don't stop this job
this job will run for one hour
so this is an important concept when
you're starting a server inside a job
that job will never end or will run into
this timeout so be very careful when
you're doing things like that
now i'm gonna go ahead
and manually stop this job you'll see
here this cancel button here
we cannot wait forever so i'm gonna
cancel it
and then this will stop
now there is a way to start a server
and there is a way to check that text
but we still need to make some changes
i'm going to go back again
to the pipeline
let's go inside the code
open the pipeline
and see what we have here now
what do we want to do so we have managed
to start this server it will run forever
but how do we test something so in order
to test something we have to execute the
upcoming command and in order to
actually get this information we need
essentially an http client we need
another tool
that will go to this address which is
you have seen there it's starting on
localhost which is the host name on port
3000
and the protocol is http
so we don't have a browser that we can
open here so we need something that is
as close as possible to a browser
so that tool is curl
so curl is a tool that will be able to
go to this address
download the website
and then we can
do something i'm going to use here a
pipe so this will send the output of
this website to the next tool
and as you remember from working with
files
we have the possibility of using grep so
grep will search for a specific string
so what is the string that we're looking
for i think the string is learn gitlab
ci i'm gonna check again against the
website to make sure that i have this
exact text here
because this is what we're trying to
find
inside a website right
so we're starting a server
then
we have this curl command and in grab
we're getting
the website and then we can search for
this string
we still haven't solved the problem with
the server running forever we don't want
it to run forever so we're gonna use a
small trick and i use here this and sign
and what will this do is to start this
process in the background
so it will essentially still start the
server but it will be in the background
and it will not prevent this job from
stopping
so when the curl command has been
executed this job will also stop
because this command will be executed
right after this one
curl will not wait for the server to
actually start
the server needs a few seconds to start
and in order to wait for that
we don't know exactly when this will
start so we're going to use another
command which is called sleep
and sleep will take a parameter here so
this will be in seconds so we can decide
how many seconds we want to wait
just to be sure i'm going to use here 10
seconds
additionally
curl is also another command which we
don't have
and this is actually a dependency of
this alpine image so this has nothing to
do with yarn or npm as serve does this
is an exception
so for that reason we're have to use
here the package manager from alpine so
a b
k this is the alpine package manager
and we're gonna add here
curl so this is how we are adding curl
as a dependency so let's give it another
try and see if this works
now if looking at the logs we'll see
that this is still failing
maybe this is not our day but let's go
through the process again and try to
understand what is going on
and generally i have to tell you we have
to get used with errors and
the more we understand about this the
more we are able to solve this kind of
problem
so we have added surf we have added curl
and we started the server we can see
here
if we're still getting this information
accepting connections at
we waited here for 10 seconds
curl
has downloaded this
and then has sent this to grab but we
are getting here an exit code 1.
because we are not seeing any errors
from curl which means that curl has
downloaded this information
we have to wonder like what's going on
with grep why isn't this information
available there in the response
now we could go and debug this a bit
more
but essentially when carl is downloading
a website it's not really downloading
what you see right now here it's
actually if you click on this
and go here to view page source on any
website
what curl is actually doing is
downloading this
now this is the
index.html file and this index.html file
will download other things in the
background without some scripts so that
information there is not really coming
from the page from this page that we are
getting with curl and curl doesn't have
the possibility of actually rendering
javascript and images and so on so it's
very basic tool
what we have here for example
is this react app in the title
so how about if we change this
and we are asserting that we have this
title so let's go ahead in the
application and figure out where this
react app appears now i change it to
something with gitlab so instead of
using learn gitlab we're gonna simply
try and use react app because we know
this is available here
so from the project i'm gonna open the
web ide
if i'm not in the right branch i can
simply switch the branch
open the file that i want to edit
so we're gonna use instead of learn
gitlab ci
i'm gonna use here react app
and we are also gonna enable the rest of
the jobs
which are the unit tests which have been
disabled
the linter has been disabled
and then we're gonna put all these
changes together
commit them to the branch we're not
gonna start here a new merge request we
already have a merge request so we're
gonna disable that if it's enabled
i'm gonna commit again
and finally the tests are working so
let's go again and inspect the job logs
so what we find here well
we have everything that we are
interested in
and particularly the last part was the
one that was failing
and now it's able to locate this inside
here so this is why you're getting back
the entire text
you'll see here react app it's in the
response
so
curl and grab now work together and this
job succeeds has been a bit of work but
i'm happy that we have this test and it
ensures that
our pipeline really works a bit better
and that we're more confident in what
we're building
i'm gonna go here to the merge request
you will see here we have four commits
we have here essentially the changes
that we made
so we reverted
all the other jobs that we have disabled
and we just have adapted this test
website
so from that point of view everything is
good we're gonna squash here the commits
so we can also modify the commit message
commit messages add integration test so
that looks good
i'm gonna click here on merge and this
changes will be merged into the main
branch
so currently our continuous integration
pipeline looks like this it is divided
in three separate stages
and the way i've structured this is just
an example there is no hard rule
different programming languages and
technologies
may require a different order you are
smart people and i'm sure you'll be able
to apply these ideas to whatever you're
doing
however i just wanted to mention two
principles or guidelines that you should
consider
one of the most important aspects is
failing fast for example we want to
ensure that the most common reasons why
pipeline would fail are detected early
for example here linting and unit test
quite often developers forget to
check their linting make a mistake or
forget to run the unit test so if we
notice that this is happening a lot it
really makes sense to put this as the
first stage of the pipeline
they typically don't need a lot of time
so the faster they fail
the better it is because we'll get fast
feedback we'll use less resources
and of course we are if we're running
here in parallel jobs that are similar
in size that's also a relatively good
way of grouping jobs together now you
also have to be very careful when you're
grouping jobs in parallel for example if
you have a job that finishes in 15
seconds and you have a job that finishes
in five minutes for example let's say
here linter needs 15 seconds unit test
needs five minutes if the lender fails
after just five seconds the unit test
will still run for five minutes there's
no no stopping there so it does make
sense to put in parallel jobs that are
similar in size
another aspect that you need to consider
are the dependencies between the jobs
so what do i mean by dependencies well
for example here we cannot test the
website until we have actually built the
website
but the linter and the unit tests they
don't depend on the build output so for
that reason we can run them before the
build we can run them after the build we
don't have a dependency there
but in this case for the website we are
dependent on the job artifacts because
we're using them for something so from
that perspective
we always need to have the build job
before here we can test the website
so if jobs have dependencies between
them they need to be in different stages
now i have to say that there is no
replacement for experimentation
and trying things on your own
if you are unsure if something works or
not just give it a try and see how far
you can go and why that pipeline fails
as you have noticed so far our pipeline
does require a bit of time
and actually optimizing these pipelines
is a lot of work so what i wanted to
show you is just a very simple way on
how we're gonna save a bit of time
throughout this course that we don't
wait so much for each of these stages
so again i'm gonna open here the web ide
and what i want to do is to essentially
restructure these jobs
now as you can notice here the build
website the linter and the unit tests
they are all pretty similar
they
all use the same image they all need to
install yarn dependencies and
they just run a command after this
so one idea would be to for example take
the linter
so yarn lint
and to put it right here after we have
installed the dependencies
and in that case we don't need this job
anymore same goes for the unit test
right we're gonna take here the unit
tests
and put them after yarn lint
and again we're not gonna need this
anymore
also not gonna need a stage
we can reduce this
to just two jobs so
this job indeed has
this image
which is the same as this one it doesn't
have any dependencies so it's just
installing surf here it's installing
curl so i don't want to really combine
this in a single job we could
theoretically put everything in a single
job
but i'm just doing it now for
performance purposes
and in order to save a bit of time we're
just going to stick to this two
different stages the build stage and the
test stage and even if you're doing here
a bit of testing it's acceptable now to
be able to save a bit of time and as i
said it's totally up to you how you
structure your pipeline but
this is why we are removing now this i
just wanted to show you how they look
like but for the rest of the course we
don't want to wait so much time waiting
for these stages to complete
so for that reason this will be a bit
easier i'm going to create a merge
request and merge these changes
into the main branch
if you're binge watching this course
make sure to take a break after a few
lessons there is a lot to take in but
you need to take care of your body as
well so get up from time to time drink
some water eat or go outside and relax
your mind and trust me taking a break is
so much more productive than staying all
day in front of your computer if your
body does not feel well this impacts
your productivity and energy levels so
i'm going to take a break as well and
i'll see you in a bit
[Music]
in this unit we'll learn about
deployments and we'll take our website
project and deploy it in the aws cloud
along the way we'll learn about other
devops practices such as continuous
delivery and continuous deployment by
the end of this section we'll have a
complete ci cd pipeline that will take
our website build it test it and let it
float in the cloud just a quick reminder
in case you get stuck or something does
not work check the video description for
the course notes which include
troubleshooting tips this sounds
exciting let's begin
amazon web services or simply aws is a
cloud platform provider offering over
200 products and services available in
data centers all over the world
aws offers a pay-as-you-go model for
renting cloud infrastructure
mostly for computation or data storage
so instead of buying physical hardware
and managing it in a data center you can
use a cloud provider like aws
such services include virtual servers
managed databases
file storage content delivery and many
others
aws started in the early 2000s and its
adoption continued to increase over time
maybe you have heard the story when the
new york times wanted to make over 1
million old articles available to the
public a software architect at new york
times has converted the original article
scans into pdfs in less than 24 hours at
a fraction of the cost a more
traditional approach would have required
and this was back in 2007
today many organizations can't even
imagine their idea infrastructure
without using some cloud components
while this course focuses on aws the
principles presented here apply to any
other providers if you don't already
have an aws account don't worry it's
quite easy to create one
enter your personal details and click on
continue
since we're using aws for learning and
experimenting with it i recommend
choosing a personal account
aws is a paid service and even though in
the beginning there is a free tier that
has some generous limits and is ideal
for learning and experimenting you are
still required to provide a credit card
or debit card for the eventuality you
will go over the free limit
i'll go with a free basic support plan
which is fine for individuals
now that we have an aws account that is
verified and has a payment
what we need to do next is sign in into
the console because from the aws console
we can access all services that aws
offers
if you're seeing the aws management
console it means that you have set up
everything correctly
and you can continue with the rest of
the course and essentially start using
aws right away
let's do a bit of orientation this is
the main page from where you navigate to
all aws services
aws services are distributed in multiple
data centers and you have the
possibility of selecting the data center
you would like to use right here on the
right side on the top of the menu
i will go with u.s east 1 north virginia
you can use whichever region you like
just remember the one you have selected
as this will be relevant later on
typically the data centers in the u.s
have a lower cost than others that are
spread around the globe
and right here you have a list of all
services available you can also search
for services in this search bar
finally i highly recommend that you go
to your account profile and enable
multi-factor authentication this will
significantly raise the security of your
account
that's about it now you can start using
aws
the first service that we want to
interact with is aws s3 which stands for
simple storage service you can find a
service by simply searching for it
you see here s3 i'm gonna click on it
and there you go this is aws s3
s3 is like dropbox but much better
suited for devops actually
for a long while dropbox was using aws
s3 behind the scenes for storing files
but let's go back to the course
since our website is static and requires
no computing power or database we will
use aws s3 to store the public files and
search them to the word from there over
http
on aws s3 files which aws calls objects
are stored in buckets
which are like some super container
folder
now you may notice that your aws
interface looks a bit different than
mine
aws is constantly improving the ui
and things may change in time however
the principles that i'm showing here
will stay the same so let's go ahead and
create our first bucket
first of all we have to give our bucket
a name and the name of the bucket needs
to be unique so i'm going to give this
bucket a unique name so that i don't run
into conflicts with anyone else who may
have created the bucket with the same
name so i'm gonna just give here my name
and a dash and after that i will give
here a date
additionally you'll have here the aws
region and in my case i'm gonna keep it
exactly as it is
then there are also a bunch of settings
that we'll not look into right now so
right here at the end i'm going to click
here on create bucket
all right so the bucket has been
successfully created
and we can go inside the bucket and to
see if there's anything in there
but at this point there are absolutely
no files of course we could go ahead and
manually upload files or download files
or things like that so through the web
interface it's possible to add files and
folders
but this is not what we are trying to
accomplish with devops we want to
automate this process so for that reason
i'm going to leave it as it is and in
the upcoming lectures we're going to
find a way on how to interact with aws
s3 from gitlab
so how can we interact with the aws
cloud and particularly with aws s3 in
order to upload our website
if you remember in the beginning we
talked about how we typically interact
with computers and that is through a cli
command line interface
so for the aws cloud we need a command
line interface to be able to upload
files for example and fortunately aws
has already thought about that and there
is an official aws command line
interface that we can use
there's also here a very
in-depth documentation about the
different services that are available
and throughout the course we're gonna
also navigate through this documentation
because i want you to understand the
process of interacting with such
services and the importance of actually
using a documentation and not just
replicating what i'm doing on the screen
now to be able to use the aws cli inside
our gitlab pipeline
we need to find the docker image and the
best place to search for docker images
is in docker hub
so here inside docker hub i'm going to
go ahead and write aws cli
and i'm going to find here we'll see it
it's under verified content
if possible we always try to use
verified official docker images i'm
gonna take this one
so
all i have to do is simply copy this
and then we're gonna go inside our
pipeline
open the web ide again
and let's go ahead and create a
completely new job here
so i'm going to call this job deploy
to
s3 and we're gonna add an additional
stage here because we need to do this
deployment after the ci pipeline is done
so we have tested everything and after
that if everything passes then we're
gonna move to the next stage which is
the deploy states and right here stage
deploy and the image that you want to
use is the one that i've just copied
which is amazon aws cli
now by default this image will not
really work the way we have used for
example the node image or the alpine
image
this image has a thing which is called
an entry point essentially when we're
starting the image there's already a
program that's running with that image
and this is something that conflicts a
bit with the way we're using images in
gitlab so we need to override that entry
point so for that reason i'm going to
move this to a new line i'm going to
write here
another property which is called name so
this is under image and this is not a
list and below it i'm gonna write entry
point and here
i'm gonna override the entry point with
this
square brackets and this quotes here so
then comes the script part and in the
script part we are essentially writing
well let's test if the tool is working
so typically almost every tool
will have the possibility of printing
out the version so the name of the tool
is aws
and then the version will be dash dash
version
now what we're interested in is using
aws cli in version two this is the
current version another version is
version one but we're definitely
interested in using version 2.
so for example here from docker hub you
can go to the tags
and you can also specify a tag if we
don't specify a tag we'll always get the
latest version
but generally it's recommended that you
specify a tag in it you go with a tag so
for example if i want to specify this
tag i'm going to copy the name of the
tag i'm going to add here column
and then the value that i want to use
it's a best practice to always specify a
tag but of course by the time you watch
this there will be newer version
typically anything that starts with two
should be good enough
so let's commit these changes in a
branch and see how the pipeline looks
like
now right now i'm getting an error and
if i'm looking inside the pipeline to
see what's going on
there are some errors
because
the stage i have chosen in this case the
deploy stage doesn't exist so the
pipeline hasn't been executed so we
still need to make some changes to it
so here where we have the stages i'm
gonna add here deploy
so now we have the stage build test and
deploy again i'm going to commit and see
if the pipeline runs
so now the entire pipeline has been
successful let's take a look at the
deploy job see exactly what has happened
there
and we can take a look at the logs here
we have used this aws cli
image
and of course we have printed here the
version so we'll see exactly which
version we're using
i've used the tag so with that tag i'm
gonna always get this version but
sometimes if you don't wanna specify a
tag it's still a good practice to lock
the version in the logs
just in case you know from one day to
the next one or like one month later or
something like that your pipeline
doesn't work anymore at least you can
compare previous logs with existing ones
and see if there's any differences in
the version that you have used for the
various tools
i'll tell you right from the start that
getting this upload to work will require
a bit of learning and a bit of steps so
we're not gonna be able to do this right
in this lecture gonna get some errors
just as a heads up but we'll be making
progress toward that goal
so how do we upload the file so let's
continue editing this pipeline now as i
said because you're going to need a few
tries and go ahead and disable the build
website
and the test website jobs and this will
ensure that we are only running the
deployed 2s3 job for the moment until
we're ready and we have tested that
upload works
i always like to make things as simple
as possible
and whenever i'm working with a new tool
i want to make sure that i don't make
any mistakes or that i can easily
understand what's going on so for that
reason i'm going to leave aside this
complexity with building and testing the
website we're going to only focus on
deploy 2s3
so we have here the aws version and then
what you're going to use here is aws
this is the name of the cli tool then
i'm going to specify the service name
which is s3
and then on the service name we are
gonna use copy right so we are copying
something to s3 now what are we copying
well for example let's create a new file
from scratch just to make sure that
everything is working properly so how do
we create a file i'm gonna use echo i'm
gonna write here hello
s3
i'm gonna put it inside
let's call this test.txt
right
so we are putting hello s3 inside this
file so we now we have this file so we
know exactly what we are uploading
and the question is where are we
uploading this where we're uploading
this to the bucket that we have created
now for that reason we need to have the
bucket name and if you still have your
bucket open you'll be able to see here
the destination now this is my
destination you will have a different
bucket name of course
i'm going to go ahead and simply paste
this
so it's s3 column forward says forward
slash the name of the bucket
then we have to specify the name of the
file so in this case i'm going to keep
the same name
it's going to be test dot ext
so we are taking this file that we have
created inside gitlab
we are uploading it to this bucket
and
the name of the file will be the same in
this case
let's give it a try and see how it works
because we have disabled the build and
the test stages essentially we now only
have the deploy to s3 so this makes the
entire pipeline execution much faster
but let's take a look why this failed
so what we did we're still printing the
aws version and then the last command
that we have executed is this one
and i cannot stress how important it is
to go through the locks and try to
understand what has happened so it says
here upload failed
trying to upload this file to this
location and it says the error
essentially is unable to locate
credentials
the thing is how is aws cli supposed to
know who we are
i mean if this would work as it is right
now we should be able to upload files to
any bucket that belong to other people
or to delete objects from buckets that
belong to other people
so we need to tell aws cli who we are
and this is what we're going to do in
the upcoming lectures and in order to
have the entire context in terms of this
we have to go through a few stages of
preparation
existence right now there's something
about this pipeline that i don't like
and that is because we have something
inside here that may change later on
and i would really like to make this
configurable and not to have this
information inside here
at the beginning of the course we looked
at the defining variables and i've shown
you how you can define some variables
within the pipeline there's also another
place where you can define variables and
for that i'm going to copy this value
and i'm going to go inside the settings
so from your project you can go to
settings here on the right hand side
and what you're gonna do here is select
ci cd
and right here in the middle you will
see variables
i'm going to expand this so that we are
able to add variables now typically here
we tend to store passwords or secret
keys but i'm going to use this bucket
name as an example for some important
features you need to know about so let's
go ahead here and click on add variable
and i'm going to name my variable aws
underscore s3 underscore bucket
and the value will be exactly what i've
copied from the pipeline now there are
some additional settings here i want you
to pay attention to
there are two flags one of them
is typically enabled by default and that
is protect variable
this flag alone is the single cause for
a lot of confusion and a lot of wasted
time for people who are just getting
started with gitlab i just wanted to
point this out
if this flag is enabled
this variable that we have defined here
will only be available to protected
branches so for example the main branch
that is a protected branch that
information will be available
in our current branch i created here a
feature branch for working with
aws cli
if i leave this flag on and try to use
this variable there it will not work
typically the idea here is let's say you
have two environments you have a test
environment and you have a production
environment
you may have different credentials for
each systems for securities reason
now you typically want to keep the
protected variables for the main master
branch which deploys to production
in this way you ensure that nobody has
the credentials to accidentally deploy
to production from a different branch so
this is a security measure now we are
using branches and we are using these
services directly so at least at this
stage we're going to go ahead and
disable this flag because we don't want
to protect this variable because
it will not be available in our pipeline
execution as we are running this on a
branch
the second flag is disabled by default
this is something that will be masked
in order to mask a variable this is
particularly useful for password so for
example if you accidentally try to print
one of these variables in your code
it will not appear there it will just
appear like a must masked out with like
simply stars
it's okay to have for example user names
or other things like this packet name we
don't need to mask this because it's not
really a secret but if we had here a
password for a password it would make
sense to mask this so for this variable
i'm gonna disable the protect variable
flag and i'm gonna disable the mask
variable flag
many people think that if you don't have
the protect variable flag the variable
is somehow public or unprotected that's
not the case it's simply available for
all the branches inside a project and at
this stage that's totally fine i'm going
to change this a bit later on but at
this point that is fine
i'm going to go ahead here and add the
variable
you will be able to see it here being
added and of course if you need to make
changes to it you can go ahead and make
changes from here
going back to the pipeline instead of
having this value i'm gonna start here
with the dollar sign
aws s three bucket
so the name has to be exactly as you
have defined it
and
don't forget to put the dollar sign in
advance because this is what makes this
a variable
we can run this pipeline again
and see how it looks like see if we
notice any changes
now if we're looking at the logs we
should be able to notice something
interesting
so what is interesting about this is the
following
we have
the same command
but now inside the command you notice
this variable so
when we're writing the command the
command that's being locked here this
doesn't change it will still show you
with the variable so it may seem that
it's not resolved but actually if you're
looking here at the error that we're
getting you will see here that the
variable has been resolved
an indication that the variable has not
been resolved is for example not seeing
this text at all
so i invite you to play around with the
protected flag and to run the pipeline
again to see what's happening
and you should be able to see here that
after s3 you'll got you will get
three forward slashes you will not be
able to see your bucket name here
so let's go back to what we wanted to
achieve to actually upload this file and
we're still getting this error unable to
locate credentials so what should we do
should we put our
aws email and password somewhere in this
variable so that aws can locate them
well you're getting pretty warm with
that
yes essentially we have to provide some
credentials but those credentials won't
be our regular email and password
because that will be highly insecure
whenever we're using a service we try to
give limited access to that so in order
to give this limited access to services
in this case we only need s3
there is also a service that manages
that
so if we go back here to aws
and search for services the service that
we are interested in is iam or yum and
this is essentially an identity manager
service that aws offers
let's go inside it and see what we can
do so first of all if you didn't
activate multi-factor authentication
you're going to get this warning and i
definitely recommend that you do that
this is just a testing account for me
which will be very short-lived so for
that reason i didn't do that at this
point
now here from this service we can create
new users essentially we want to create
an user
that will be able to connect to s3
so from the left hand side here
let's go to users
and i'm gonna add a new user
so we have to give here this user a
username
can be any user typically i'm using
something so that i know why i created
it so i'm going to call this gitlab i
know exactly that this user is intended
for gitlab
and we have to select an access type
now what we are interested in is also
called programmatic access so we're
going to click this and you will see
here that this enables an access key id
and secret for aws api cli
and so on so we're interested in having
this for aws cli so this is why we are
creating this user and we are enabling
this programmatic access
we don't need a password we don't need
this user to have access to the
management console like we do so for
that reason that's sufficient let's go
to the next part which is the
permissions so essentially the
permissions tell what the user is
allowed to do
and permissions in aws i'm going to say
it's not an easy topic so i'm going to
go the most straightforward way i'm
going to attach an existing policy so
i'm going to go here to attach existing
policies
in this search bar i'm going to select
s3 i'm going to search for s3
you're going to get some predefined
policies so policy is essentially like a
set of rules that we can apply to a user
and the set of rules that we're going to
use here is
amazon s3 full access so essentially
we're gonna give this user access to
everything that is aws s3 so
we should be able to create new buckets
should be able to delete files and so on
so a bit more than what we actually need
for this use case
but just to simplify things i'm gonna
give this full access to the user but of
course this is a topic on its own
let's go to the next page we see the
tags we don't need to add any tags here
and then we'll be able to
review what we're trying to do
and we can go ahead and create this user
so now we have successfully created a
new user
and aws has created something for us and
that is an access key id and a secret
access key
to put it in plain english this is like
a username and a password you will see
here that the password is not even
displayed
so what are we going to do with this
information so first of all let's go
ahead and copy the access key id
go inside gitlab
again going to go to settings ci cd
and expand here the variables
and let's go ahead and add a new
variable
i'm going to start here writing aws and
you will see there already some
predefined things that pop up
so one of them is aws access key id
this has to be written exactly as you
see it here
there's something that's different about
this
away cli will not be able to pick up
this variable it will look exactly for
this variable name and will
automatically pick it up without us
doing anything else so it has to be
exactly as it is i'm going to paste here
the value of course this is as per my
account so you'll have a different value
and i'm gonna disable the protect
variable flag because we want to be able
to use this in a branch as well
i'm gonna go ahead add this variable
and going back to aws i'm gonna also
show here the secret access key
of course i'm gonna delete this right
after recording
but i'm showing you just to know exactly
how it looks like it's also important
that you don't add any spaces or
anything like that
so i'm going to copy this secret access
key
and go here add a variable
and i'm going to start typing aws
secret access key and i'll paste the
value here
i'm going to disable the protect
variable flag
and click on add variable
finally there's still another thing that
we need to configure and that is our
region
so again i'm going to add here variable
start typing aws and we have here the
default region so when we're setting
this variable
all services that we use will be in this
region and we don't need to specify the
region all the time aws know exactly
where this bucket or any other service
is located
and we cannot simply write here anything
we have to write exactly as aws uses it
internally so what do i mean by that
well let's go back to the aws console
and you will see here the s3 service and
recently visited so this will make our
life easier in terms of
grabbing this information
and for example for my bucket this is in
u.s east north virginia
what we're actually interested in is
this code
so i'm going to copy this information
and paste it here so this will be the
default region
and again i'm not going to protect this
variable
and
i'm going to add it here
what i forgot to do in terms of the
secret
access key is i haven't masked it so it
would be idea to go back to it click on
this edit
and you will see here this flag
because this is essentially a password
and a click here this flag to mask it
and update it and then you also have
here an overview like which one of them
is protected
which one of them is masked and of
course if you need to inspect some of
these variables you can go back and
click on them and you'll be able to see
the value but list on this overview here
they are hidden
there's also this possibility of copying
the value without revealing this can be
useful as well or you can click here on
reveal values and they will be displayed
all right so it seems that we have
everything in place now at least we have
these credentials
and because we named them the way we
named them aws cli will automatically
pick them up so there's actually nothing
that we need to change in our pipeline
so for that reason we can simply go
ahead and rerun the same pipeline once
again
i'm going to go here to ci cd pipelines
go here to the job that failed
and here i can simply click on retry
this will start the exact same job once
again
all right so this already looks so much
better
the job has succeeded we don't see here
any errors aws cli is telling us which
files have been uploaded
so we could jump into s3
and take a look inside our bucket to see
if we have any files here you will be
able to see here our
test.txt file right inside here say when
it was modified and so on
we can download it if we need to
but essentially this has been the first
major step in terms of interacting with
the aws cloud
all right so we have made some progress
and we have managed to finally upload
this file
but if you remember we have an entire
website with a lot of files
so you know going file by file and
uploading that is not really the way to
go
so i can make sure that whatever we have
inside the build folder it's going to be
synced to our bucket
now if you remember in the beginning i
mentioned the documentation the
reference for the aws cli essentially
for any service there is here
documentation there is here an
additional command so we have used aws
s3 as the name of the service
so in this list of services here you
will find
s3 somewhere
so here we go this is s3 so i'm going to
click on it
i'm going to be honest with you in the
beginning this documentation will look
very scary
but if you take
a bit of time if you have a bit of
patience and you go through the
documentation
this is the way to really master the cli
commands that you will be using and this
doesn't only apply to aws cli applied to
any tools out there so reading the
documentation looking at all the
parameters everything that you can do
with this is really super helpful so for
s3 you will see here a lot of
documentation but also at the end you
will see here a list of available
commands
so we have used
cp for copy so we've copied this file
and it's also definitely possible to
copy an entire folder
but i wanted to show you also different
command which is sync now temporary
syncing something means that whatever we
have on one side we have on the other
side as well
for example to ensure this with copy we
first have to remove the folder just to
ensure that we really have everything so
for example if we added the file or we
have removed the file we don't want to
have those files on s3 anymore if we
don't have them on our website anymore
so for that reason using something like
sync which ensures that all the files
are in sync does make a lot of sense so
we can go here on sync
and we'll
tell right from the description it syncs
directories and
essentially it ensures that whatever we
have there on one side is also available
on the other side so how do we use this
let me
demystify this and take a look at our
existing pipeline that we have here so
first of all we're gonna give up on this
test file that we have uploaded here
this was just for
testing purposes and to make sure that
we have everything set up correctly
so we're gonna use here aws s3 so the
command will be sync
so what are we thinking we're syncing
the
build folder
so instead of that file we're going to
have an entire folder
and the question is where are we syncing
this we're syncing this to the bucket so
we're going to remove this part here
because we are going to put it directly
inside the root
and additionally we're going to also add
a flag
so if you're looking here through all
the options that are available one of
the options should be dash dash delete
it will essentially ensure that if we
delete some files
during our build process which existed
previously in previous builds that are
also deleted during the sync
so if i had a file in the build folder i
synced it in the last build then i later
removed that file i want that one
removed from s3 as well
so i'm gonna add here
delete
so this essentially should be enough to
upload
our build folder now in order to get
this to run of course we have to
re-enable our previous jobs
so now build and test are enabled
gonna commit these changes and see if
this command worked
and the pipeline is now successful and
we're most interested in this last job
that we have executed
and now if we're looking at the logs
we'll see exactly which files we are
uploading so we'll see here
uploading this uploading that so these
are all the files that we have inside
the build folder
what's also important to notice is you
notice here this delete so this file is
then deleted because it no longer exists
in the bill folder it actually never
existed in the build folder but sync
detects that this file doesn't exist
there and says okay if it doesn't exist
in the build folder it doesn't make any
sense to stay on s3 and goes ahead and
removes it
so let's take a look at the s3 service
i'm going to refresh this page and take
a look to see how it looks like
so now we are able to see
all the files that we are actually
interested in there all have been
uploaded here
and we made a very important step
towards hosting our website in the aws
cloud
now currently the files that we have
uploaded here they are not publicly
available whenever we create a bucket by
default it will be private to us so
nobody else external has access to it
actually that's kind of like the normal
use case you don't want the files that
you're putting here to be available for
everyone but of course there are use
cases when you want to make these files
accessible to anyone else and actually
quite a lot of companies are using s34
storing files that they offer for
download because it's so much cheaper
than hosting them on their own website
now in order to make this bucket
publicly accessible we need to change a
few things
and we're going to start here with
properties
and actually what we are definitely
interested in is enabling
static web hosting so again i'm here in
my bucket inside properties
right at the end there's static website
hosting
i'm gonna go ahead here click on edit
and we're going to enable
static website hosting
and
the hosting type will be host a static
website
and there are also some settings here
that we are gonna input
websites typically have an index page
which is a start page and also they have
an error page
for this application that we have the
index page and the error page are the
same and this is the index.html file if
you look inside the bucket you should
see the index.html file
so this is exactly what we're going to
have here for the index and the error
so i want to save these changes
and we're still under properties
and if we go back here at the static
hosting part
you would see here that now we have an
address so now our website is hosted on
aws
we could also get the domain and point
this to this address but for what we're
trying to do right now this is more than
enough so we can go ahead and click on
it
and in the beginning we're gonna get
this error and there's still a few
things we need to configure don't worry
about it
just wanted to point out the address and
where you can view it
so let's see which other settings do we
need to make i'm gonna go here to
permissions
and you will see here the first thing
that appears is access bucket and
objects not public
whatever we have here in the bucket is
not public so this is why even if we
have enabled static website hosting we
still cannot access this information so
let's take a look at how we can
enable public access i'm going to click
here on edit
and i'm going to disable this block all
public access
and save the changes
and again because this is like a major
thing ableist really wants to make sure
that we know what we're doing so i'm
going to enter here confirm
i've been going to the website we can
try a refresh and it will still display
the same error page here so there's
something that's still not working
properly
what we need to do in addition to what
we did here with in regards to the
public access
is a bucket policy
now essentially we need a policy for the
objects that are inside the bucket
don't want to get too much into the
details but essentially we need to write
this policy so we can go ahead here and
click on edit this is like policy
generator now what you see here is json
and this is the format in which this
policy will be written here
there are a few things that we need to
change about this policy so essentially
we can go ahead here and add an action
so let's search for example for s3 i'm
gonna select hit here
and the permission that we are looking
for is essentially get object
i'm going to click on this get object
but additionally there are also a few
other things that we need to change here
just to make sure that everything is
working properly and this changes will
be made in text
but you also find a template in the
course notes just in case something
doesn't go well
you will have the possibility of using
that
so essentially gonna give here a name
and i'm gonna call this public read this
is just a name to identify this policy
and the principle here we need to be put
between
double quotes
and i'm gonna put here this star and
then the action will be
get s3 object that's allowed the effect
is allow
and resource we also need to specify the
resource and the resource is our bucket
i'm going to copy this name it's
essentially the address of the bucket
and i'm going to put this here also in
quotes
and i'm going to add here very important
a forward slash
and this star which essentially means
that
everything that is in this bucket
can be
retrieved get object
it is allowed
so this is essentially our policy for
public
reading all right i agree it's not so
easy for beginners but let's hope we
haven't made any errors here and that it
will work as expected i'm gonna click
here on save changes to apply this
policy
you will see here warnings all over the
place you will see under the bucket in
red publicly accessible
access public
so
aws is really trying to tell you hey
watch out uh if this is not what you
intended or this is not what you want
this bucket is publicly accessible so
really really make sure that you know
what you're doing
but for us it's fine this is what we
wanted to have
and now by refreshing this page
we're getting the website that we have
created
and now congratulations really this is
absolutely amazing we created pipeline
that now takes every commit that we make
and deploys it in the aws cloud we take
it through all the stages
but we only have to make the change and
the entire process is automated so if
you manage to follow along up to this
point
wow
i'm sure that you have learned so much
and trust me
we're just getting started there's still
so much more to learn and i'm super
excited about the upcoming steps
now let's go back to the pipeline that
we have designed now
and i'm still here in an open merge
request
and
if i'm looking at the pipeline i have
here all the three stages so the build
the test and the deploy
now if you think about it this really
doesn't make a lot of sense
and what doesn't make sense is to deploy
to s3 from a merge request or from a
branch now if we think as s3 being our
let's say our production server or
production environment
then it means that anyone who opens a
merge request and tries out some
small changes
if the build and the test pass this will
automatically get deployed to production
and actually this is not what we want
we want
inside a merge request or as long as we
are in a branch we just want to run the
build and test essentially to simulate
the execution of the main branch
and then
only when we merge this we want to run
the deploy so we want to deploy to
production
so in order to achieve this we still
need to make a few changes to our
pipeline
now this is how the configuration looks
like at this point
and the changes that we need to make are
here in the deploy 2s3 job
now how do we exclude this job
from this pipeline which is running on
the branch and to ensure that it only
runs on the main branch gitlab has this
feature which is called rules now rules
allow you to create really complex
conditions and i won't get into those
but we're going to use a relatively
simple condition which will check if we
are on the main branch or not
now in order to set up rules we're going
to go to the deploy 2s3 job
and what i'm going to write here is
rules
this is a completely new keyword
and here we can define a list of rules
now we're going to add only one rule and
this will be a list so you notice that
i'm starting a list and then we have
here an if
column
and now after the if we can specify a
condition
so in a condition we're typically
checking if something equals or does not
equal something else
so
in this case you want to check if the
branch we're currently at
so we have here something i don't know
where we're at
equals so we're gonna make two equal
sign
the main branch right so if
we are on the main branch only then run
this right
now we don't want to put here something
hard-coded so we cannot
know in advance like which is this
branch name where we are currently
evaluating this condition so in my case
i mean feature deployed to s3 or
something like that so it doesn't make
sense to add that there to to check this
it needs to be dynamic so in order to
have something dynamic we need to use
some variables
now luckily gitlab comes with some
predefined variables
and one of these variables is
ci commit ref name so i'm going to
search here for ref name
you will see here
so see i commit ref name
this will give us dynamically
the branch or tag name for which the
project is built
so we can use this as a variable
and i'm going to write here dollar sign
this one
so this will be
evaluated to
our current branch now with any of these
variables if you're not sure what they
do how they look like
simply use here echo
and just keep something like this for
debugging purposes in your pipeline
until you get
familiar with the values that you're
having i'm going to remove it because i
don't need it but
for you definitely recommend use echo to
inspect the different
values that you're using
if you were on a different branch this
would be something else so
if this equals main then we're gonna
essentially
run this job otherwise it will be
excluded from the pipeline
still having something hard coded here
is also not something that we like doing
yes we could keep here main
but there are also variables that can
handle this so another variable that we
can use is default branch
so it should be ci default branch and
this variable will give us dynamically
give us the name of the default branch
so if later on for whatever reason we
decide to switch from master to main or
from main to
something else
then we don't need to worry about these
pipelines because the default branch
will automatically get updated in this
variable
and then
we can use it directly here so again
i've added here another variable which
is the ci default branch so now
everything is dynamic so this rule makes
sure that when the current branch
equals the default branch this code gets
executed in our case right now for maine
will have this job
in other pipelines this job will get
excluded not be part of the pipeline
so i'm going to commit this
and i'm going to take a look at the
pipelines after this
so what i invite you to do is to go to
cicd pipelines
and now our pipeline only contains two
stages
so we have the build and the test stage
the deploy job was completely removed
i can also inspect the merge request and
take a look at what is going on here and
also i see that this pipeline has been
updated it contains only build and test
so at this point i would say okay i'm
pretty confident that this functionality
is working properly gonna click here on
merge
and also let the main
pipeline run
so again if we're looking here cicd
pipelines
we will now see that
the main pipeline has started so this is
on the main branch
and now this pipeline contains the three
jobs required so we have build test and
deploy
so now the main pipeline is also working
we have deployed again to s3
but how do we know if our website is
still working
again we could go to the address again
hit the refresh button check again if
it's working
but again that's not really the point of
automation we want to make sure that the
entire process is automated
so if this is a worry that we have like
is the website still working that we
have deployed
it's probably time to
add another stage and to test after this
deployment if everything works correctly
on the website or at least as much as
possible
so let's open up the ide and take a look
here at adding another stage
so we already have here build test
deploy
so
probably the next stage should be
let's call it post deployment
so this will be
after the deployment
and then it's probably time to also add
another job
i'm going to call this production tests
and i want to make sure that the stage
is the right one
let's post deploy
and what i'm proposing is to simply run
a curl command so that's pretty similar
to what we did here
so simply going to go ahead and copy
this
of course this has to be under the
script block
and there are a few things that we need
first of all we need a docker image that
has curl
and one option would be to search again
docker hub for such an image but
essentially any docker image that has
curl would be sufficient
so i can go ahead here on docker hub and
search for curl
and what i've used in the past is curl
images curl
but probably also one of these verified
content images is probably just as good
so the address to this image is this one
so this is what we need to do without
docker pull
so we have here image
and paste remove this docker pull
that's the name of the image
and because curl is such a generic tool
don't need to specify a specific version
what we're doing is pretty basic and i'm
pretty sure it's not going to change
very soon
the other thing is the address right so
the address where we have deployed this
and this is available in s3
so if you're going back in s3 to our
bucket
looking here at properties
and right at the end this is the address
right so can go ahead and copy my
address
go back to the editor
i could paste it here right
but again we had a discussion about like
not having
you know things that could change later
on inside our pipeline or have it all
over the place so again let's go ahead
and define a variable now this time i'm
gonna define a variable within the
pipeline itself
that's also totally fine and also way on
how to do things i'm going to define
here variables block
and let's call this variable
app base url
of course you're free to name it as you
wish column
and then i'm going to paste here the
address to it
so this is now the full address to it so
all i need is
this this is the variable name
and here instead of writing something
like this
and simply go ahead
use curl app base url
i'm going to search for react tab
because this is what we have actually in
the body of the index html that we are
grabbing
this should be enough at least to test
that what we have on s3 is still
reachable that at least this text is
still available there
additionally we need to make another
configuration because otherwise as it is
right now this will also run inside the
branch
so i'm going to copy this rule that we
have here on deploy to s3
same rule is valid here we want to run
these jobs only in the main pipeline
so i'm going to go ahead commit these
changes and merge them into the main
branch
and i'm anyway pretty confident that
this pipeline will work without any
issues so there's no additional review
that i need at this point i'm going to
simply merge when the pipeline succeeds
and i'm going to grab a coffee until
this is merged
so after a few minutes here in the merge
request we'll see a few things so first
of all we have here the pipeline for our
branch with two stages
we have to build and the test
that's it
after we have merged this then the
pipeline for the main branch has started
and this pipeline then has four stages
build test
deploy
and post deploy so essentially the stage
that we have added right now and this
contains the production tests let's take
a look at them to see what has happened
here
so we have executed this command
curl was able to download the website
has passed this information to grep and
grab a search for react app in the text
and somewhere here was react app so for
that reason
everything worked out successfully so we
know that website is still there it's
still working so that's perfect
so let's take a minute and take a look
at what we did so far so this is our
main pipeline right this is the pipeline
that now deploys to aws s3
and we have the build and the test this
is what we essentially call continuous
integration right this happens also in
the merge request but also here we are
rechecking that our build is still
working and let those tests are executed
here the second part
this is the cd part in ci cd
now cd can mean continuous deployment or
continuous delivery i'm going to explain
a second what that means
right now we're kind of doing continuous
deployment in the sense that every
commit that goes into the main branch
will actually be deployed to production
we have automated the deployment to s3
and we said that
you know our s3 bucket it's hosting our
website and is essentially our
production environment that the whole
world can see
now this is a very simplistic view
on
ci cd
now quite often pipelines also have a
staging environment or a pre-production
environment essentially if we make
changes to our deployment to s3 and
something doesn't work anymore
we're not really testing this before
and the main branch may still produce
some errors and again we come back to
the same problems we had when we did ci
when
nobody else can work on a project
anymore
so for that reason it kind of makes
sense also to add another environment at
least if the environment if there are
some issues with the environment
before production and the main pipeline
breaks at least we haven't affected the
production environment so it's still
good right now we're just deploying
anything and we're testing afterwards
what is a staging environment so a
staging environment is essentially a
non-production usually non-public
environment that is actually very close
to the actual production environment
right so we want to keep things as
similar to the production environment as
possible
quite often we use automation to create
these environments and to ensure that
they're really identical we haven't done
that we have used manual work to
actually create the s3 bucket and we did
some automation afterwards but ideally
we would create this entire
infrastructure automatically
so the idea is to add a staging
environment as a pre-production
environment essentially
we want to try out our deployment on
pre-production before we go to
production so in case it fails the
production environment is unaffected
the main two concepts i want you to be
aware of is continuous deployment and
continuous delivery now with continuous
deployment as i said every commit that
goes through the pipeline
would also land
on the production server in the
production environment
with continuous delivery we're still
using automation
and every successful merge request again
triggers the main pipeline which leads
to an automatic deployment to the
staging environment
however we don't go directly to
production there is like a button that
you click in order to promote a build
from the pre-production environment to
the production environment
so these are like the differences
between continuous delivery and
continuous deployment
in upcoming lectures we're gonna get a
bit more into them and you're gonna
better understand like what they really
mean
so now it's time for you to practice a
bit more and at this point i have an
assignment for you
and the assignment is essentially you
building a staging environment
and i want you to follow essentially the
same process as we did when we created
the production environment i also want
you to make sure that you write some
tests that ensure the environment is
working as expected
please pause the video and take this as
an opportunity to practice along more
both with aws and with building the
pipeline
i hope you had a good assignment and
that everything is working properly in
this video i wanted to show you how i
would do something similar
so first of all i'm going to start with
creating the bucket and i'm just going
to copy this name that i already have
click here on create bucket
and essentially i'm going to call this
staging essentially the same name but
i'm just adding staging to it
and in the beginning i'm going to leave
all settings as they are
and in the upcoming steps i will
essentially ensure that this packet is
public
so they are the same steps as before and
i'm not going to go again over them
so after a few clicks i now also have
this staging bucket also as public and i
have enabled
website hosting which means
you can go inside the bucket you can go
here to the properties
and then
right here at the bottom i will see this
address which we will need later on
first of all let's begin with the name
itself so i'm going to copy it and i'll
have to go inside gitlab and save it in
a variable
so here in gitlab i'm going to go to
settings ci cd
go here to variables
what you'll notice here is that we
already have an s3 bucket
of course that's kind of an inconvenient
at this point so we'll need to figure
out exactly how we can manage this but
i'm going to go ahead
and also call it aws
s3
bucket
i'm going to call it staging
i'm going to add this thing that will
make it different
essentially now we can protect this
variable because we don't want to deploy
from a branch anymore
so it definitely makes sense to have
this protected
masking it doesn't make any sense at
this point
all right so at least now i have this
i'm gonna copy the name so that they
don't forget it
and let's go inside the project open the
web ide and start making some changes to
the pipeline
now first of all because this is a
pre-production environment we need to
define another stage
before we deploy to production let's
call this deploy staging and of course
what we need to do here is to
define a new job
now most of this job is pretty similar
to what we already have here in terms of
deploy to s3 and also in terms of the
production test that we have here
so it kind of makes sense to copy
everything that we have
and paste it here again
and let's call this deploy to
staging
and we can call this deploy to
production
just to have like
more clarity in terms of where we're
deploying and what we're doing
also we need to have the right stage
so the stage name is deploy staging
apart from this we are using the same
image
we still want to run this on the main
branch
and the only thing that we need to adapt
here is the bucket so it's going to be a
little s3 bucket staging
and again the test that we have here
they can be called staging tests
we'll see here that
you know the editor is complaining about
the duplicate key
so that's a good thing because you know
exactly what we need to fix
so then we have the staging tests
and also here
where we need another base url
so that's also something that we need to
consider
i'm gonna add staging to this one as
well
and from aws i'm gonna copy the url
paste it here you can notice that we
have two different urls
so let's double check everything
we have added a new stage
deploy staging which is before deploy
or we can even call it deploy production
right so we have even more clarity just
need to make sure that we are adopting
this everywhere
so we have here deploy staging
and then we have deploy production
but then we have post deploy now we also
want
to have this testing
after the staging so we need
something like test
staging for example and we can call this
test production right so we're deploying
to staging we're testing the staging
if both of them are successful then we
go ahead and deploy to production and
after that we test again the production
so let's make sure that we have the
right stages
otherwise we're going to get some issues
so deploy production
yes test
production
test
staging
deploy staging
we have the right bucket name
here we don't have the right url we need
to grab that as well
for staging
all right and all of a sudden our
pipeline got a bit bigger but no worries
one last check
deploy staging test staging deploy
production test production
deploy staging is the stage
we're using the staging bucket
paging tests we're using the staging url
test staging deploy production
test production all right
i'm going to go ahead
omit these changes and we'll see how
they work in the main branch
and a few minutes later after the main
pipeline has also completed
we'll see now that we have here a bunch
of stages so
after the tests then we're deploying to
staging we're testing staging deploying
to production we're also testing
production
of course you could go ahead and
combine the staging so for example
because our tests are very simple
there's nothing that prohibits us from
just putting this simple test inside the
deployed job itself so that will save us
some stages here but i just want to
demonstrate like how how longer pipeline
essentially looks like
and what's the meaning of the stages so
most importantly now if something
happens with the deploy stage the
pipeline breaks here production
environment is unaffected we don't have
to worry about it
so we have time to fix any problems in
our deployment
if you're looking again at the pipeline
well
you know all this staging environment
has really created
a lot of duplication and all these
variables with the bucket now we have
ideal ss3 bucket with staging
we also have this base url and the
staging url
obviously we have now two environments
but we haven't really figured out a way
on how to properly manage this
environment
luckily there is a functionality that
gitlab offers for managing these
environments
going inside the project you will find
here
on the left hand side deployments
and inside deployments there's this
optional environment
what is an environment
staging is an environment production is
an environment
wherever we're deploying something that
is an environment and it really makes
sense to have this environment defined
somewhere and to work with the concept
of environment instead of fiddling
around with so many variables that's
really not the best way on how to do
that
so what i'm going to do here i'm going
to create a new environment
and i'm going to call this environment
production
i'm also going to get the environment
url from the pipeline so let's remember
this is
the production
url so
let me get that and i save it here
and going back to environments i'm going
to create a new environment
and this will be staging
again going back to the pipeline
copying the name of the environment
and putting it here
what gitlab will also do is to keep
track of deployments on different
environments now currently we don't have
any deployments but we can directly open
the environments from here so in case we
forget where the our environments are we
can easily click on this open
environment link
especially for non-technical people that
are also working with gitlab it's easier
for them to see exactly where is the
staging environment what's the url don't
have to ask someone can just directly go
to the respective environment and see
that respective version so very very
useful feature in terms of environments
but what does it do for our pipeline
well
i'll tell you what this will do we're
going to remove this from here right i'm
going to go ahead first of all this is
out i'm not using this anymore
second of all i'm gonna go back to
settings ci cd
and expand here the variables
and i'm gonna go here to this aws s3
bucket
i'm gonna click here on edit
and this is essentially our production
environment this is for production
and now we can also give a scope so we
can tell gitlab hey
this variable is associated with
production and not with something else
so we can essentially scope it
and of course in this case because we're
using it in main only we're going to
also protect this variable
i'm going to go ahead and update here
and the same goes for this other
variable right now we don't need this
staging added at the end we can just
call it aws s3 bucket
and we're going to select here the
staging
environment scope
and update the variable so now we have
two variables
that share the same name
but now they belong to different
environments
now the idea
is to do the following we need somehow
to adapt our pipeline
and let's begin here by
deploying to staging
first of all we have this aws s3 bucket
so i'm going to remove here staging
from the end
and additionally we need to tell gitlab
hey this deployed to staging this is
associated
with the staging environment i'm gonna
say here environment staging
there are still a few things i would
like to change first of all the entire
pipeline right now is too long
we still have this staging test and
production tests and because this is
just one curl command we can just move
it away from here
i'm going to remove this stage all
together
and all i want to do is to add it here
on deploy to staging so essentially
right after you have deployed we're also
using this curl command
it's pretty similar to what we're also
going to do on production
but as you probably know this already
this app based url doesn't exist anymore
we have removed those variables
and we need to find a way to get our
environment url
and luckily again
gitlab to the rescue
there is a variable i'm going to go
ahead and search for environment
and i'm going to have here the ci
environment name environment slug
environment url so this is what we're
interested in the environment url i'm
going to copy this
and i'm going to put it here in the curl
command so i'm going to send the curl
command directly to the ci environment
url
same goes to the production deploy to
production
i'm going to add it here
so in this situation the production
tests they also don't make any sense so
i'm going to remove them
and all these extra stages that we have
here test production
it's not going to be needed
test staging it's not going to be needed
so now we have much more simpler
pipeline but we're still achieving the
same thing
most importantly we are using
these environments
we still have an error inside here
but i just gonna commit these changes
let the branch pipeline run merge these
changes into the master
we're gonna take a look at the main
pipeline to see which errors we still
have there
now if we're looking at the main
pipeline you will notice something
interesting
deploy staging
has passed it's working perfectly
you will see here curl ci environment
url
it's fetching the page
it's passing however
if you're looking here at deploy to
production
it's all of the sudden complaining
it's saying here that aws is three
bucket
parameter validation failed
invalid bucket name
so what's going on
well the following thing has happened
we somehow did not associate this with
an environment or the environment is not
correct so we need to go back and see
why this job does not have access to
this environment variable
i'm going to go ahead here
and
take a look again at the configuration
to make sure that the configuration
itself of the job is correct
what do we have here
or we have deployed to production
but as you can notice
i haven't defined an environment
right so i have defined an environment
for deploy to staging but i haven't
defined an environment for deploy to
production
by looking here at the variables
you will see that this aws s3 bucket
is now scoped only for production
and because this job
doesn't say anything about production
this environment is not exposed in the
production job
so to be able to solve this we also have
to add here environment production
i'm gonna go ahead and copy this
and the environment will be production
and of course unfortunately this time we
have to go again through all the stages
the merge request
and committing this in the main branch
and just a few minutes later the entire
pipeline will then succeed so we have
deployed the staging we have deployed to
production everything seems to be
working fine
we can take a look at the jobs to see
what they're doing
and
we'll see here that everything worked
out without any issues
and of course we can also go here to
deployments
environments
and here we are able to see the staging
environment and the production
environment and we can easily open them
and we can see like what was deployed
when was it deployed so it really keeps
track here of the different
environments and the deployments that
took place
so we see here on production there's
only one deployment
in staging we have two deployments that
we have committed so we are essentially
keeping track of what is going on on
this environment
you know what
i'm still not super happy with this
pipeline i mean generally when i see
that a lot of things are repeating
it kind of makes me wonder if there's
not a better way so if looking here at
the deployed staging and we're looking
at deeply production
well essentially at this point because
we have used all these variables
these jobs are almost identical the only
thing that is different is the different
stage
different job name and we're specifying
the environment but the rest of the
configuration is identical
and yes the answer is yes we can
simplify this even more
so essentially we can reuse some job
configurations so i can go ahead here
and i'm gonna copy this
and i'm gonna go here and i'm gonna
define
essentially a new job i'm just gonna
call it deploy
this will be a special kind of job it
will be a job that has a dot in front of
it and as you remember we have used the
dot notation to disable jobs
by having this we can essentially have a
configuration here
we don't care about the stage right we
don't care about the environment so this
is something that is not in common with
the rest it doesn't even have to be a
valid
job configuration we have just put here
the parts that are really important for
us
and then
in these other jobs we're going to keep
what we need
so what we need we need a stage and we
need an environment and of course we
need the job name
and this other part here
we can simply write something like
extends
so this will be the extents keyword
and what are we extending we are
extending dot deploy
that dot in front
is very important so don't miss it
and the same goes for deploy to
production
i'm going to remove everything
i'm just going to keep here the extents
and make sure it's properly indented
so deploy to staging deployed to
production
we now have two simple
jobs here
essentially the deployment part is the
same
this also gives us peace of mind because
if we're making changes to the
deployment part we're only making
changes here so if we make a mistake
there
the chances are we're going to be able
to catch it before it goes to production
let's commit this give it a try see how
it works and it should essentially work
the same as before
and after a few minutes if we take a
look at the main pipeline
we'll see that it works as it should
work it looks as before and this is
exactly what we expected we didn't want
to see anything else but the pipeline
working but now we have a much simpler
pipeline configuration
and now feel it is time for another
assignment
now let me tell you my idea now we have
this pipeline and we are testing with
the curl command that that specific text
is on the website
and that's fine it ensures that the
website is still working
we currently haven't really made any
changes to the website itself we haven't
added any text or removed anything
how can we make sure that you know with
what we actually built here
actually lands on the staging and in the
production environment and it's not
somehow a cache or something old there
maybe you know maybe the deployment is
not even working and you're getting the
older version and we think that
everything is fine
so here's my idea
what if we add another file in our build
let's call it
version.html for example
and inside there
we put a build number something that is
all the time different with each build
so for example it will increment from
one two three four and so on so that
with every build we can identify to
build number
and we can check which version has been
deployed to staging and production
how about this idea
and in order to get you started i'm
going to show you how to get this
information inside there how to get
this build information this dynamic part
maybe this is something that
right now you don't know exactly how to
do it so no worries i'm gonna get you
started but the rest of the assignment
will have to figure it out on your own
trust me you already
know all the concept needed in order to
implement something very simple
so i'm going to go ahead here and define
a variable and i'm going to call this
variable app underscore version so
essentially let's say that this is our
application version so want to have
something like 12
13 14 and so on
now again when we're thinking about
something dynamic we have to think back
to the list of predefined variables that
gitlab offers right
so on this list
there are various variables that we can
use
including something that is related to
the pipeline id
so if we're looking for pipeline
underscore id
find here some
pipeline ids that we can use so these
are variables that of course change all
the time they are injected by gitlab so
we can use them in our jobs
so we can get here like an instance
level id this typically includes like
very large numbers because there are a
lot of pipelines on a gitlab instance
but you can also get like a project
level id so this will be something we
can easily relate to it's and we're
going to see it increment all the time
so i'm going to get this variable
and i'm going to use it here
so i'm redefining this because i want to
give it a bit of meaning i could have
used this directly somewhere this is
really your solution
but if i'm using here app version
i'm very clear that this is the
application version that we're using
here not just some random id
so that's it i'm gonna
let you do the rest of the assignment so
just to recap
here somewhere in the build
add a new file
which is called version.html
add that new file
put this app version inside that file
and then
when we're testing our deployments
including staging and production so here
create a new curl command that will
check that that application version is
actually available on that environment
okay so i hope that you have managed to
solve this on your own i already feel i
gave you like quite a lot of hints but
just to make sure this is how i would
solve it so let's go here to the build
website
apart from all these things that we're
doing here what i want to do
additionally is to create this file so
again
in order to create this file we have to
first think about the name so it's going
to be inside the build folder right this
is
this is what we're deploying and the
name will be version.html
and what we're doing is we're taking
this application version
so in order to get the application
version inside the file gonna use echo
we're gonna print the application
version and then eventually again
redirect it to the file
so this is enough to create this file
to put it inside the build folder which
already exists build yarn build has
created that
and because this is dynamic it will be
available there
the next step
is part of the deploy template so i'm
working directly in the template here
so we can essentially duplicate this
command
we're going to the environment url and
we hope that we don't have a forward
slash already gonna check that quickly
i'm gonna go here to deployment
environments
i'm gonna go to staging
click on edit
and i'm noticing here i don't have a
forward slash so that's already good and
i presume that
the production environment is also
similar but just to check
i did
i don't have a forward slash okay so
inside our configuration i'm gonna add
here forward slash
i'm gonna write here version
and what are we looking for well we're
looking for the application version
and because the application version is
simple number we don't need these quotes
here so we can just write grep
app version and that should work
so already as part of the merge request
as soon as the build has completed i
want to go inside this build website and
i'm going to take a look here at the
artifacts to see if this artifact
contains this
version.html file
so i'm able to see it here version.html
it has a size that is not zero that's a
good thing
and we can also download all the
artifacts or just look at a single file
so after clicking on this
somewhere here on the screen it will
open up this web page essentially so
this is the build number 35. it's pretty
small but you should be able to see it
on screen as well so this is part of the
file so it's already looking good when
this much request is completed i will
also take a look in the main branch
now the main pipeline is also working
makes me very happy because
i now have more confidence in what is
going on in this pipeline i have
confidence that if i'm making a change
that change actually gets deployed to
staging and production and we have this
additional check then in place to ensure
that
all right so let's recap a bit what we
did
the first part is the ci part continuous
integration the second part is cd
continuous deployment now we have a more
realistic continuous deployment pipeline
we're testing something and then we're
first deploying to staging making sure
that on staging everything works
and after that we deploy to production
but what is a continuous delivery
pipeline this is exactly what i wanted
to show you essentially a continuous
delivery pipeline is just a pipeline
where we don't automatically deploy to
production essentially what we want to
do is add here a button and only when we
are sure that we really want to make
that change to production we can click
on that button and make that change so
let me show you how to do this
i assure you it's super super easy
so inside the pipeline configuration
the
job that is affected by this change is
deploy to production
so here on deploy to production i'm
going to add a condition and the
condition is when
and we're gonna write here manually
it's actually when manual not manually
so this will tell gitlab that we only
want to run this job manually so we need
some manual intervention
gonna commit these changes and we're
gonna take a look at the final pipeline
now this is the final pipeline and i
want you to notice something
for deploy production
this job now looks a bit different right
you look at deploy staging you click
here on deploy production we'll say here
this is a manual action and we have here
an additional button right
if we also go to
our deployments and we take a look at
environments
we'll be able to see here like what we
have on each environment
so you'll see here
if we're going here on staging
this is a staging environment
and of course here inside the staging
environment we can go ahead and write
here version.html
so we're getting here
on the staging environment for version
40 right so this is the version on the
staging environment
and if we're opening up to production
environment
it looks absolutely the same
but if we look at a version that html
you'll see that this is a different
version right
on staging and on production we now have
different versions because our pipeline
has not deployed to production yet
so in order to deploy to production we
have to click this button
and only then
will the deploy to production job start
so this is essentially the difference
between a continuous deployment and a
continuous delivery pipeline
what we have here is a continuous
delivery pipeline we're continuously
building packages of software we're
deploying them to staging
but we're not automatically deploying to
production without that manual
intervention
for some organizations this is mandatory
and this is why i'm also showing you in
some legacy systems
you cannot always deploy everything
without checking a few things in advance
now if we're looking here deploy to
production has also completed
so we can take a look here if i'm gonna
refresh this website i'm gonna get here
version 40. and here on the staging also
version 40. so now
both
staging and production have the same
version now i hope that the difference
between continuous delivery what we did
right now
and continuous deployment where every
commit that lands in the master branch
gets deployed to production makes more
sense now
hey how are things going are you like
the course so far you're following along
let me know by leaving a comment in the
section below or by sending me a message
on twitter or linkedin or on any social
platform you can find me i'd love to
hear from you and to know how are you
using this course
we are at the end of this unit so i'm
gonna grab a coffee and i will see you
in a bit
[Music]
so far we have worked with a static
website and deployed it to aws it's
probably one of the easiest scenarios
involving gitlab ci and aws however
modern applications tend to be more
complex and most of them use docker
nowadays so in this section we'll
dockerize our website and instead of
copying some files to aws we'll be
deploying an application that runs in a
docker container to do that we'll build
a docker image as part of the build
process store it in the gitlab container
registry and deploy to a service on aws
called elastic beanstalk so if you're
eager to learn more let's jump right
into it
when we use a cloud provider like aws we
can rent virtual machines that have a
dedicated cpu
memory and disk storage
and we can use any operating system we
desire
but this also means that we are in
charge of managing that machine
we need to ensure that it's secure and
that all software running is
updated this is often too much overhead
especially for some types of
applications
but there is a way to take away this
complexity and focus only on the
application we want to deploy
aws elastic beanstalk is a service that
allows us to deploy an application in
the aws cloud without us having to worry
about the actual virtual server that
runs it
this is a great way to reduce complexity
and it's probably one of the easiest way
to deploy an application in the aws
cloud
by default elastic binstock can run
python java node.js php and many other
types of applications but it can also
run docker containers which really gives
us a lot of flexibility
we'll be running a web server
application that serves our simple
website files
so this time instead of just uploading
some files to aws
we are providing the entire application
which is self-contained in a docker
container
i'm sure you'll be amazed by how easy it
is to run an application here in the
background we will be using a virtual
machine but we don't need to worry about
managing it
however at this point i need to warn you
about potential costs
while running these servers for a few
hours or days
will most likely be free or cost you
only cents
if you let the service run for a month
you may get some unexpected charges on
your card
even if you are not actively using a
service once you have created it it uses
resources in the cloud
so stop any services if you are no
longer using them
find a way to set a reminder so that you
don't forget about them
with that being said let's start using
elastic bean stock
so let's go ahead and create an elastic
bin stock application
so i'm here in the aws console
and the first step would be to search
for elastic bean stock so i'm going to
write here eb
and you will see here one of the results
is elastic bean stock
so since i have no applications here i'm
getting this getting started guide so
i'm gonna click here on create
application
so let's call this application my
website
you don't need to include any
application tags
and here on the platform
there are different platforms that are
supported
but what you're actually interested in
is in the docker platform so that we can
essentially deploy anything we want
i'm going to select here docker i'm
going to leave the defaults as they are
and the first step would be to start
with a sample application
so we're not going to upload any code
we're going to let elastic beanstalk
create this instance this application
and after that we're gonna add our own
application on top of that
so i'm gonna click here on create
application
it will typically take a few minutes to
get this to run
and in the end you should see something
that looks like this
so what has happened here
well we have created an application
and we have initialized a sample
application that elastic bean stock
provides
in order to actually run that
application this wizard that we have
used is set up has also created an
environment
so we have
applications which is like an umbrella
for environment
so if i'm looking here at environments
you'll be able to see here that we have
an environment that is called
my website dash nf
it belongs to the application my website
and then you get some information in
regards to when this was created
under which url is this available
which platform is this using and so on
in order to see like what this
environment is doing we're gonna click
here on it you'll be able to see here
link
so if you click on this link this is the
sample application that was deployed so
it's just an idea
tells you that everything is working
properly that we have nothing to worry
about this entire setup has worked
without any issues
now the question is what has actually
happened in the background
in order to understand that we're going
to go here to the services and we're
going to take a look at ec
and right here ec
and that is ec2
the service that we are actually
interested in
this stands for elastic compute
these are essentially virtual servers
that we can create here but we haven't
actually created one
but if you're looking here at instances
you'll see that we have one running
instance
and this instance is called my website
dash and
you will see here which kind of an
instance this
this is a virtual server that's running
here and this is the server that's
actually running our application
additionally if we're going here to s3
we'll be able to see that we now have an
additional bucket
so we still have our buckets that we
have used for hosting the website
but now elastic bin stock has also
created a bucket
so actually what elastic beanstalk has
done
has created this required infrastructure
in order to run the application we
didn't have to worry about creating that
but this is why it took a few minutes to
create this entire thing
now let's go ahead and try to understand
how we can deploy something on your own
like how can we get our own application
to work
and because we're using docker
we need to provide
a manifest file essentially
a file that describes the application
that we're trying to deploy
so i'm here inside the project again
and if you go into the templates
you will find here a file called
docker1.aws.public.json
and this is the manifest file that i'm
talking about
it essentially tells aws which container
we want to run because we have selected
a docker platform we can only run docker
containers there
and this is a public container
the name of the image is nginx which is
a web server
but what we want to try here is to
actually use this configuration to use
this file
and to deploy this application to aws to
make sure that this deployment process
is working and this is again something
that we'll do manually at this point
just to make sure that everything works
properly
so go ahead and download this file
and after that let's go back to aws
and open up elastic bean stock
here inside the environment we'll have
the opportunity to upload a new version
of the application you'll see here right
in the middle
running version this is the sample
application then we have this option
upload and deploy and we want to upload
that json file
so i'm going to go ahead and select the
file and i can also write here a version
label
this will be sample application
version one that's totally fine and i'm
gonna go ahead and click on deploy
and what will happen is
elastic beam stock will take this file
and then we'll start a deployment we'll
start here updating the environment
of course this will take a few minutes
but in the end what we want to see here
is health status okay wanna see that
everything is working properly
and wanna see that this application has
been deployed and is available at this
address
and now we're seeing here status
is okay so health is okay everything
seems to be working properly you can
also go ahead and refresh this page just
to see here which version is running
you will see here that the running
version is sample application one so
this is exactly what we have deployed
we can open up this address
and we'll see here welcome to nginx
so this is the welcome page from the
nginx server which we have deployed by
having this json file which describes
which container we want to use with
elastic bean stock
so in order to actually deploy our
website
we need to create a docker image we need
to provide this json file and of course
we also want to automate everything so
this is what we are going to do in the
upcoming lectures
so how do we create a docker image with
our website
a docker image is created by following a
set of instructions something like a
recipe
we store these instructions in a file
called docker file so let's go ahead and
create one
so here from the web ide gonna go ahead
and create a new file
and you will see here in the suggestions
one of the suggestions is docker file
so which are these instructions that we
write inside the docker file first of
all we have to start with a base image
essentially an image that we want to add
something on top of it
in our case because we want to deploy
web server with our files
we're going to start with the engine x
image it is exactly the same image we
have used in order to test our
deployment to elastic beanstalk so i'm
gonna write here from nginx
and additionally what i highly recommend
is writing a version so writing a
specific tag
so in order to know which tag to choose
i'm going to go to docker hub
i'm going to search here for nginx
i'm going to take here the verified
content
so this is the official image for nginx
i'm gonna take a look here at the tags
and let's search for alpine because
alpine generally provides us with a very
small docker image
so what i'm searching here for is a
specific tag
so this here would be a very good tag to
use just as an example i'm going to go
ahead and copy that
and here in the editor
column
and the version
so you have to be very careful how
you're writing this has to be something
like this
so we're starting from this base image
so we have everything that is in the
base image we have there so we already
have the application essentially the
application is the web server
now the next step is to actually add our
files which are in the build folder
and to put them on this web server
and we do that by using the copy command
and right here copy
so what are we copying we're copying the
build folder
then we have to specify where we are
copying it now by default there is a
folder
where nginx will store
files that we want to serve and that
folder has the following path forward
slash user usair share
nginx
and then html
so we're moving this folder
inside html folder so this is everything
that we need to do in order to build our
docker image these are the only
instructions that we need at this point
we're getting
this base image nginx in a specific
version because we're using this tag
and then the next instruction is copy
everything that is in the build folder
and move them to this html folder
just because we have created this docker
file doesn't mean that something will
automatically happen we still need to
make some changes to our pipeline
and because we're already making changes
and because we want to deploy to elastic
bean stock we don't really need this s3
deployment anymore so i'm going to
remove essentially all the jobs that are
related to s3 this includes deploy to
production deploy to staging this deploy
job which is just a template and also
test website we're going to introduce a
better way of testing
so i'm going to remove all of them and
what remains is the build website
and of course also the stages here they
can be removed so what we're going to do
is we're going to introduce a new stage
let's call it package
and we're going to associate this stage
with a new job i'm going to call it
build docker image and now
the stage will be packaged
so how do we build the docker image well
it's relatively simple the command is
docker
built
i'm going to also add a dot here because
that's going to make a reference to the
current folder and the current folder
contains the docker file that we have
created
in order to be able to run this docker
command
we also have to define the image that
we'll use
and the image will be docker now just
using this docker image will not work
we're gonna get an error
the reason for that is the docker
architecture is composed of a client and
a server essentially what we have here
docker this is the client and the client
sends some instructions to a server
actually to the docker demon which is
the one who builds the job
and in order to get access to a daemon
inside gitlab ci we need to use a
concept and that concept is of services
we want to define here a tag services
and this contains a list of services
that we can start
and what we're starting here is actually
service called docker in docker
you're going to see me using here this
docker in docker tag
so this service is another docker image
that can build docker images cannot be
accessible for us over a network
and
docker here which is the docker client
will be able to talk with the daca demon
which is here inside this service
i know that now in the beginning this
may
seem all bit confusing but this is like
the minimum what we need in order to be
able to build docker images from gitlab
what i also like to do is to set some
tags so i'm going to go ahead and write
a fixed stack for docker and for docker
in docker so i'm here at docker hub
and this is the docker image you will
find the link in the course notes
because this is something that's not so
easy to find actually
not so many people are actually looking
for
docker and i'm going to use this version
here
i'm going to go ahead and copy it
and i'm going to add it here to my job
image
and additionally there's another tag
with docker in docker and this is the
tag that i'm gonna use for the docker
daemon
i'm gonna
remove here dent
and this will be the docker in docker
image you'll see both of them have the
same version
additionally when we're building images
we also like to specify tags like label
this will help us identify
the images that we create because we can
create multiple images of course
in order to tag images we first have to
specify an image name and also the tag
so we can use here dash d
we're going to keep here this dot at the
end that's very important
don't forget it
and what we'll use here is this is the
list of environment variables and one of
these environment variables is this ci
registry image so we're going to use
here ci registry image don't forget to
put a dollar in front of it
this will build the latest tag so this
is a tag that always points to the
latest image that we have created
and additionally i'm going to create
another tag
which still contains cr register image
i'm going to add here the dollar in
front to make it a variable
i'm going to add here column
and we're going to use the app version
that we are still
having here in our job
so we are creating two tags
so don't forget the dot at the end this
is super important
this is one tag that we are creating
and this is the second tag that we are
creating
and this variables will ensure that we
have the right name for our docker image
additionally in order to make sure that
we have indeed built these docker images
we're gonna use here docker
image and ls actually we are building
only one image but we are tagging that
image with two different tags
the latest and the app version so this
will show us all the images that are
available with all the tags that are
available in this instance
i'm not gonna run this job only on the
main branch i'm just gonna run it inside
the branch i'm still here in the branch
playing around
so we're gonna see how this looks like
after we execute it
and once the execution is done we're
gonna jump directly into the build
docker image and try to understand what
has happened here so we'll see what
there are a bunch of locks that have
been generated
but most importantly what we want to see
here is which docker image are we using
so we'll see here this is the docker
image which is darker and then we're
also this is new we're starting this
service with docker in docker
so the service will be available over
the network inside this image that we
have right now this will give us the
docker client
and there are a lot of locks here and
they're not really so relevant the
interesting part
comes when we're actually
building the image
and you'll be able to see here this is
our command
there are some steps how these docker
images are being built docker works with
the concept of layers
but we won't go into that but this is
exactly what's happening here is every
essentially every command that we're
executing will create an additional
layer on that image
we have successfully built this so this
is what you want to see
it has been successfully built and then
we have also the two tags that we have
created you will see here the latest tag
and this is also the version tag now
they both point to the same image
but they are different text and you will
better see it here with this command
that is listing images so this is here
the essentially the name of the image
we'll see here the tag and you will see
that internally the image id is the same
so we have the same image but with two
different types
so now we have successfully managed to
build and tag our image
as you might have guessed
the docker image that we have just built
has been lost as soon as the job
finished
the docker image that we have created is
not a regular file or an archive that we
can just declare as an artifact and
upload it to s3
when we want to preserve a docker image
in this case this docker image that we
have created here
we need to save it in a registry
for example docker hub which we've been
using to find out tags and images that
we can use
is a public registry with docker images
however typically our projects are not
public so it doesn't really make sense
to use docker hub so for that reason
we need a private registry
both aws and gitlab offer private docker
registries and for this example we'll be
using the docker registry offered by
gitlab and you'll see here on the left
hand side
packages and registry
and we're going to use here the
container registry because docker is all
about working with containers and of
course at this point
there are no container images stored for
this project so alone just building that
ochre image does not automatically add
it to the container registry actually
this is called pushing so when we want
to save a docker image in a registry we
need to push it to the registry
so let's go back and make some changes
to our pipeline
so let's take a look
how do we push so the command in order
to push something is docker push
and we actually want to push all tags so
we're going to use here parameter
dash dash all dash tags
and then we're going to specify here the
ci registry image so this is in term of
pushing
but
where are we pushing
and especially if it's a private
registry
don't we need to log in somehow
yes that's correct so alone pushing
this will not work in our case we need
to do something before we push and we're
going to do it right here in the
beginning
because in case there are some issues
which the login we want to know as soon
as possible and not only at the end so
the command to login is docker
login
relatively easy
and we're going to specify username and
password
for this service we're not actually
using our username and password that we
used to log into gitlab we'll use some
variables again that will give us some
temporary user and passwords don't
really care so much about that but
essentially this is what we're to do so
if you're looking here
at the variables that are available
we'll find here ci registry see a
registry user say a registry password
first of all where do we want to log in
this is the cia registry
so we need to specify where do we want
to log in
and additionally we need to specify our
username and password
so we typically specify the username and
password like dash u
and then specify the username
and we're gonna use another variable ci
registry user
with the dollar sign in front of it
that's very important
and additionally we can specify password
dash p
and we'll see here ci registry password
so these are all the credentials that we
need in order to log in
in more recent versions of docker just
specifying your password like this is
not really the best way to login
you may get a warning and it's possible
that in future releases this argument
this dashb will not be available anymore
so what i like to do is the following
i'm gonna remove it from here just gonna
copy this variable
and
actually what we can do here is we can
say to docker login get the password
from the standard input and i'll explain
a second what the standard input is you
want to write here dash dash password
dash std in this is the standard input
so the standard input is essentially
something that we are piping from
another command
and that other command in our case will
be echo so we're gonna echo this ci
registry password but we're not gonna
display it in the logs we're gonna use
this pipe
so this will be available in the
standard input for the docker login and
docker login will look at that standard
input and we'll see oh okay the password
is coming from there so we're going to
grab it from there
using it in this way will ensure that
this password doesn't get exposed but
really for ci in our case it will not
get exposed anyway
but it's any good to know
and this is why we have this construct
here so once again we are echoing this
password and we're sending it to docker
and docker login will know that this
password is coming from the standard
input
and apart from that we have the
parameter with the user or docker login
where are we logging in to the registry
make sure that all the variables that
you are using here have a dollar sign
before them otherwise they will not be
resolved as variables
so let's give this a try as well and see
if our image lands up in the registry
the build docker image job has been
successful we can take a look at the
logs to see exactly which tags we have
pushed
and you will see here
this are the tags that are available so
we had tag 46 and latest
and this is pushing the tags
to the registry
so no errors here and what we can do
next is to go here inside the registry
inside the container registry
and we'll see here this root image
and if we take a look at it we'll see
currently we have two tags we have tag
46 and the latest tag will also tell us
the size of our image because we are
using alpine as a base image also our
images are relatively small so that's
definitely a good thing
so now we have successfully built this
container
but how do we know that application is
actually working how do we know if nginx
is serving our files
if we have the right files and if
everything is working as we think is
working before we actually move on to
the next step which is deploying to aws
so for that reason it does make sense to
do some accepting testing on the docker
container itself
just to make sure that we have
everything as we expect
so with that being said let's go ahead
and add another stage i'm going to call
this stage test and of course we'll also
have to add another job
let's call this job test docker image
i'm going to assign the stage test
and let's think about like how we can
test this
essentially the way we're testing this
docker image is not much different than
the way we have tested for example a
deployment or any other things in the
past
we can still use curl to do that so for
example i'm going to write here curl
we need here an address http column
forward slash forward slash
we don't know the address
but then again we can use
grep to search for example for the app
version right
and of course we can also search for
anything in the page that a website has
but say for example here we're going to
check the version
that
html that we have so just want to make
sure that we have the right
app version
and remove one of the dollar signs here
so what do we need okay we need
curl so we need a simple image that has
curl so we're going to use curl
images slash forward slash curl
so that should be enough to get this
but the question is how do we start this
container right
this is where the part that we have
learned before can be very useful and
that part is services so again we're
going to take advantage of the services
to start the docker container that we
have just created
we're gonna write here services
and this time that we'll do is in this
list we're gonna define the name
this will be the name of the image and
the name of the image is of course
dollar sign ci registry image
and the tag will be the app version we
don't want to use the latest i want to
go exactly like what is a current tag
that we want to see
so this will help us start the image
and additionally what we can do is to
specify an alias an alias allows us to
give a friendly name so that we know
where this service is available over the
network
so i'm just going to give the alias of
website
and here in http
the address that gonna use is simply
website
so http column forward slash forward
slash website
gitlab will take care of starting this
docker container
registering it in the network as website
and then we can simply call it in our
curl script with website i'm gonna go to
version.html
and inside we're gonna search for the
app version
so let's give it a try and see how it
works
and the confirmation
that indeed our docker image is working
properly can be obtained from this test
docker image job
so in this case
indeed we have checked that
the docker image is starting an http
server
and that the files that we have uploaded
in our case this version.html
it is available there
and it contains the application version
that we expected
so with that being said in this case we
now
know that we have a docker image
that works and we can deploy it to aws
if you remember the first time that we
have deployed an application to elastic
beanstalk
we have used this json file which
described which docker image we want to
deploy
in order to automate this process we
kind of have to do the same thing in
other words to give elastic bin stock
this file
now whenever we're interacting with aws
services we need to
provide some files most of the time we
need to do that through s3 so we first
need to upload those files to s3 and all
other services can read from s3 and have
that information
so in order to automate this we need to
generate essentially this json file
upload it to s3 and from there we'll
tell elastic bean stock to start a new
deployment
so going back to the pipeline what we
need to do is to re-enable the deploy
stage and the deploy to production job
this time focusing on deploying to
elastic bean stock
so let's go ahead and add a new stage
deploy
and of course also a new job here
deployed to production
since we will be using
aws cli i'm just gonna add the basic
structure that we need to this job in
order to be able to use aws cli
so using aws cli as a docker image we're
overriding the entry point
this job is part of the deploy stage we
have set the environment to production
and we are starting our script
now if looking at the files here
we'll see here in templates that we have
this docker run that aws
the name of the file is not that
important
the format of the file is very important
because this file tells
aws elastic bean stock what we are
trying to deploy
and it will say here that this is our
image
and this is our tag
so we have them here as variables
but additionally because this is a
private registry
we also need to provide some
authentication information and that
authentication information is another
file
so that file is this oauth file
and in this auth file we will need to
add a token that gives access to the
registry
and essentially what we need to upload
to s3 is this file docker run and this
auth file which is actually linked from
here
it's mentioned here of that json
so let's go to the pipeline and quickly
add these files
i'm going to simply paste here the
configuration required
so now i've added this copy
configuration to the script so we're
still using aws s3 copy it's pretty
similar to what we did before
in terms of copying files to aws s3 so
i'm going to skip a bit this part
now as you may have noticed
these files contain some variables
and those variables won't get
automatically replaced so if we upload
the files as they are
they will not get replaced second of all
we don't even have the right paths here
they are in templates and not in the
current folder where we're executing the
script just as a second thing
but i wanted to show you something very
important and that is how to do
environment variable substitution in
files and for that we're going to use a
very cool command
it is env so from environment subs
so relatively easy to tell what this
does it replaces environment variables
then we need to specify like what is the
input file and we do it with this
smaller than sign essentially
and then we're going to go here and say
something like templates
and give here the name of the file
and then we will have to specify the
output file that will be generated
and the output file will be this one so
the name of the file will stay the same
the location will change it will be put
in the current folder and this is
perfect for the next command that we'll
be using
we're doing this environment
substitution replacing all the variables
here
for the auth file just as well
so i just can replace that
there and there
so any environment variables that are in
these files will get replaced
in order to use this command we need to
install a utility
which is called get text now this
doesn't come directly in this amazon
image so this is something that we need
to install additionally i'm going to use
this package manager to install this
dependency which is called get text
and get text has this tool for
environment substitution i'm gonna also
add this flag here this will essentially
answer with yes any questions that this
installer may ask because we are in a
way that we cannot interact with an
installer
we're gonna specify this and say okay
just install it if there are any
questions answer with yes just to ensure
that the installation process works
without any issues
now we have this so we can do
environment substitution of course it's
going to be very nice to actually take a
look at these files so we're going to
use here cat
just to make sure that these
environments were substituted as we
expect them
and as a final check we should also go
in these files and make sure that we
have all variables here
so
see a registry image
app version this is something that we
already defined
so we have this information here
aws s3 bucket
this is relevant
for where we are uploading these files
now because we are using elastic bean
stock an elastic bin stock has already
created an s3 bucket
well maybe we should use that one so i'm
going to switch here to the s3 service
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
copy this name
could have used this other
package that we have created here but i
don't want to put anything any
credentials in a public folder so
with that being said i prefer to use
this bucket that is not public
and here in the environment variables of
the job we still have this aws s3 bucket
for production
so i'm gonna click here to edit it i'm
to change here the value
i'm not going to protect this variable
because i'm still in a branch and i'm
going to update this
so at least at this point we have
everything let's see this other file the
auth file
you'll see here in the auth file there
is this deploy token
now what is the thing well we have
pushed our docker image in the gitlab
repository but aws
has no credentials to connect to it and
again we're not providing username and
passwords not our account username and
password
we will generate a token and gitlab
allows us to generate a deploy token
that can be used by aws to login to our
private docker container repository
and pull that image
so in order to do that from settings
we're going to go here to repository
and we'll see here deploy tokens as one
of the options
and here we can create a deploy token
so we're going to name it aws so that we
know why we have created it and i give
the username aws
and the permissions that we need is read
repository and read registry
i'm gonna go ahead create this deploy
token
this will be created here
this is essentially like a password but
it will only be displayed once so i'm
going to go ahead and copy this and i'm
going to create a new variable to store
it
i'm going to call this variable gitlab
deploy token
and the format how we'll store this
information is i'm going to write here
the username aws
column and then the password that i've
just copied
i'm not going to protect this variable
but i can just as well mask it just to
be sure
now here inside the pipeline we still
need to do a small change to the
pipeline itself to the script itself
and
the thing is we need to convert this
username and password to base64 because
this is what we need inside this
configuration json this is what aws
expects
and in order to convert something to
base64 it's relatively easy
so for example say you have here a
string right hello
you can convert it to base 64 by simply
piping this and writing here base
64. this will output the string encoded
as base 64.
now of course we don't want to have
anything hard coded here this is why we
have defined this variable so we are
going to use here
gitlab deploy token right
and additionally we want to make sure
that we don't have any new lines or
anything like that in our token so we're
going to pipe them again to another
command
and this command will remove any new
lines that exist here so
so this end here with the backslash
this will be a space essentially so if
there are any spaces they will be
removed
additionally we need to set this into a
new variable that we can replace
so i'm gonna put here
a dollar sign at the beginning
i'm going to put this between
parentheses
and what i'm going to do here i'm going
to export
so this is
a way to create an environment variable
but from a script and the name will be
deploy
token
right and equals this expression so what
we have here
this part is an expression
this will be evaluated
and whatever output comes from this it
will be stored in this deploy token and
this deploy token
is exactly what we have here in our
pipeline
so before we commit these changes we
only are interested in making sure that
this job works well so what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna simply disable all the
previous jobs i'm gonna put a dot before
them
so that they don't run
and after that i'm gonna commit this
pipeline and let's see it in action
and it seems that i'm in luck no errors
while running this job let's take a look
at the logs to see if we have everything
and indeed it seems here that something
is missing right
some information has been replaced
the image
is replaced here i have the version
i have here the bucket that's definitely
working fine
here in the odds the registry is correct
but if i'm looking at last information
it is missing
so let's try and debug and to understand
why is this information missing there
so here's the pipeline let's double
check if we have everything correct if
we have used the right variables so
gitlab deploy token that should be the
name of the variable that we have
already find in gitlab as a variable so
that seems to be fine
deploy token is exactly that what we
have used in the file we can double
check again the file
and see here it's exactly deploy token
so that seems to be working well
so what is going on
let's take a look again at the pipeline
to see if there are any clues why this
may have failed
you know again
here we don't see it
but let's take a look at the commands
that we have executed to see if there's
anything suspicious in there so what did
we do
well first of all we have just started
the script here we have aws cli great we
are installing here get text
so that seems to be working
don't see any errors up to this point
and then we're exporting this variable
right we're running this command this
expression
and then if we're looking here at line
77 we're seeing here td command not
found
so apparently this expression that we
have placed here gets evaluated into
this variable
but when it fails
it doesn't feel the job
i'm going to open up here the pipeline
and let's take a look at the deploy to
production
so this is the td command that we have
used it should actually be tr
which
stands for translate
now this was just a silly mistake but it
just goes to show how important it is to
actually read the logs to understand
what's going on now we have both files
all the variables have been replaced
including this time in the auth file
and we can also jump into s3
and take a look at this bucket here
and we'll be able to see here the docker
run file and the auth file
they are now inside s3
docker run tells essentially contains
information about what are we trying to
deploy
links and mentions this oauth file which
contains authentication information
about how to connect to our private
registry
now let's continue with the actual
deployment so we have copied here the
docker1.aws.json
and the auth.json file and they are in
this s3 bucket and now we can initialize
the deployment and the deployment
happens with the aws cli but this time
we'll use a different service so the
service to which we're trying to deploy
is elastic bean stock so i'm going to
use aws
elastic bin stock
and this is something that is done in
two steps first of all we have to create
an application version so the command
that i'm going to use here is create
application version with dashes
the next command that we need to run is
update environment so i'm going to copy
this
and i'm going to write here update
environment so why are these two steps
necessary in the first step
we are taking this docker run file
and we are creating a new application
version
and then once this application version
has been created
we actually tell elastic bean stock
which environment we want to update on
elastic bean stock we have the
application but there can be multiple
environments in our case we have a
single environment but theoretically
it's possible to take one version to
create it once and to take it through
different environments but in this case
we only have one environment so maybe
this is why it may look a bit weird in
the beginning but these are the steps
that are required in order to get this
to run now just saying create
application version and update
environment is not actually sufficient
in order to get this to run we need to
specify some additional parameters
and the first parameter is we need to
identify the application right
so this is done by writing here dash
dash application dash name
and if we're looking here
inside elastic bean stock you will see
here this is the application name i'm
going to copy this as it is here
and of course i have the possibility of
putting it here directly like
application name like this
but i don't want to do that i want to
take advantage of variables
there are multiple places where we can
store this but i'm just gonna put them
here inside the job itself so we can
add here variables block
and for example i'm gonna call this app
underscore name
column
and then this will be the value my
website so whenever i need to use this
i'm going to put it here
so application name
dollar sign
and i'm going to reference the variable
now there's something you need to pay
attention here
because my website is composed of two
strings so there's this space here in
between
if we put this like this
this variable gets replaced it will look
like this
so this command will think that my
application name is my
and then that website
is some other command that we're
executing or some other parameter that
we're giving here and this is not
something that is recognized
so in order to get around this we need
to put this between codes
so we'll have this string between codes
because this why it will know okay it is
my and website it contains also the
space and the word after this
so again i'm gonna also put the variable
here between quotes
and this application name is also needed
for the update environment command so
i'm going to copy that there as well
additionally when we're creating the
application version
we need to specify like a label or which
version we are deploying
we already have an application version
here so it does make sense to use that
so i'm going to go ahead and write here
dash dash version
dash label
don't worry if this goes on a new line
it's just the way it's edited but
actually the command is on a single line
and i'm gonna use here app version
and this here for update environment yes
it does also make sense to specify the
application version
and i'm gonna add the same command here
the same parameter version label
to this command
now also when we're creating this
we need to specify somehow this file
right
so elastic bean stock will not know
which bucket is this file how can i read
it and everything
so for that reason we also have to
specify that
and we're going to use this additional
parameter source dash bundle and this
will allow us to specify
an s3 bucket
and the s3 bucket will
equal this time the bucket that we have
used
so it's this one here
and we also have to specify
the name of the object that we're
referencing and this is s three key
you need to pay attention how you write
this it needs to be exactly
as i have written it here
but i also noticed people in the
beginning
they don't understand when they are
specifying these additional parameters
here is not for example it's not equal
application name equals app name it's
just a space and then comes the value
here this is a bit
different because this entire thing this
entire configuration here
is a value that will be read later on
so for that reason here it's okay to
have this equals but otherwise there are
no equals in these commands
all right so to create the application
version we have specified the
application name we have specified the
version label
and additionally we have specified this
source bundle so essentially
where is the file that tells us what we
should deploy
this is almost the same as when we have
uploaded that file manually but with
that we have also triggered the
deployment automatically so we have done
two steps in one step
here we are doing it in two separate
steps
so the next part is after creating this
version is to update the environment
so we have here the application name we
have here the version
for which application are we deploying
this which version are we deploying
the next step would be to also specify
which environment are we updating i'm
going to write here environment name
and we also need another variable for
the environment i'm going to call it
here app
and name you're free to name them as you
wish
and again i'm going to go here to
elastic bean stock and i'm going to copy
this i just want to make sure that i
have everything exactly as it is in
elastic beanstalk if i specify something
else
then it's not the same
so the environment name will be here
and as you can notice here this doesn't
have any spaces so we don't need to put
this value between codes
and also all the other values that we
had here there are no spaces so we don't
need to put any quotes there but if any
of these parameters would have a space
that value would need to be between
quotes
finally let's also go ahead and
re-enable these jobs because we'll still
need a docker image now
so we will run the entire pipeline and
check if our deployment is working
properly
however when we take a look at the
pipeline we'll see that the deployed
production job has failed so let's jump
into the logs try to understand what has
happened and why this job failed
you can see here the commands that we
have executed so copying these files to
s3 still works so no problems there the
last command that was executed is this
one so elastic beanstalk create
application version so
there's a good chance that
this command is responsible for whatever
error we're getting here and then we
need to look into the logs and see what
is the error
and you can see here it says something
access denied essentially it's telling
that
our user
which is the gitlab user that we have
created if you remember we have created
this user with programmatic access
is not authorized to perform
some action so create application
version
if you remember we have selected that
the user is allowed to work with s3
resources right so uploading files
deleting files things like that with s3
that works
but we haven't authorized our user to
work with elastic bean stock
so we need to change that
so from the aws console let's go ahead
and open the
im service for identity management
we'll open up our user
we see here this is the username gitlab
and what we can do here is essentially
to attach additional policies so we have
here this
amazon s3 full access so that works but
now we want to add an additional policy
so we're going to click here on add
permissions
and going to attach existing policies
i'm going to search here for elastic
bean stock
and i'm going to give here
administrator access for aws elastic
bean stock
now i'm not going to go into this
policies in very detail we're just
interested in getting this to run
but of course if you would use something
like this in production you would need
to be very careful about what each user
is allowed to do
so
just keep that in mind just using these
very generous policies
in production is typically not a good
idea
so i'm going to add these permissions
then
and now we'll see that our user
now has this additional permission here
so we can now work with elastic
beanstalk
so going back here to the logs
instead of re-running the entire
pipeline we can just go to this job and
hit this retry button
and it will retry the same job we
haven't changed any files
and dynamically this policy should now
be applied to the user
and hopefully this job will work so
let's take a look to see what the job is
doing
and now this time it looks much better
so
we have no errors
and let's take a look at the first
command create application version now
we have executed this and we're getting
back a response right
so it's going to tell us again like the
application name which version we have
which bucket we're using
which is the name of the file and so on
it also starting to process this
and the next thing what we're getting
is the update environment so that work
without any issues it's going to tell us
again what is the environment name
so we can take a look at that
application name the version
and also some technical details about
this
so we can take a look back into the aws
console and and look here into the
elastic bean stock service
to see what's going on and we'll be able
to see here running versions is 60. i
can click here on the environment
just to make sure that we indeed have
everything the health is okay
so we can also go ahead and click on
this url
and this will open up our website so it
does seem to work very well
so now we have manually tested that the
deployment has been successful
but how about that we check in our
pipeline that the deployment has been
successful and we can use the exact same
approach that we have used so far i'm
going to jump back into the pipeline
and here inside the deploy to production
job essentially what we want to do is to
use this curl command so it should be
pretty similar to what we have here
when we're testing the docker image
i'm going to add it here to a new line
of course we also need to get the
address itself of the application of the
environment and if you remember we had
something for that already we just need
to update the url for the application
so i'm going to simply copy this url
here
and from gitlab i'm going to go to
deployments environments
and for the production environment i'm
going to go ahead and change some
settings
and we're no longer using the s3 url
we're using this one and remove here the
forward slash so this will be my
external url for this environment
and what we want to use here is of
course the variable that will get us
this environment
and from the predefined variables
probably remember we have used this in
the past ci environment name slug url
we actually want the url so i'm going to
copy this
get here into the pipeline configuration
and instead of website
gonna also replace http because i don't
need that anymore
so i can use ci environment url forward
slash version
and then we're getting that version from
there
now i'm gonna tell you if we leave this
command as it is right now
this will not work
and the reason for that is
when we are updating this environment
aws needs just a few seconds to actually
do this deployment to put the new
version on the environment this is not
instant
but the connects command will run
immediately after we have essentially
triggered this update
and that environment may not be ready or
may still have the older version so for
that reason this curl here will fail so
we'll not get this response the
deployment cannot be verified at this
point that it has been successful or not
so what we need to do here is to wait a
bit so what we can do is
of course to use something like sleep
and wait for like 10 seconds or
something like that
but in aws there's a better way to do
that when we're using the aws cli
we have a tool which is called weight
so
weight is an option it is for various
services that are at aws including for
elastic bean stock so we can write here
elastic bean stock weight
and then what are we waiting for we are
waiting for this environment to be
updated so i'm going to write here
environment
dash updated
and then we need to specify the
application name the environment name
and the version label right so
essentially everything that we had here
on the previous command
i'm gonna simply copy and i'm gonna add
it here to the new line
and this command will do the following
it will essentially in the background
it will check with aws hey
are you done updating that environment
no not yet i need some time okay
wait a bit and then we'll try again hey
are you done updating that environment
okay i'm done good and then we can stop
waiting and then the next command the
curl command can run and then we can
check if indeed the correct version has
been deployed and if our environment is
working properly
so i'm going to go ahead and commit
these changes and we'll let the entire
pipeline run and see how this goes
and the pipeline is still successful so
we can take a look into the deploy to
production job and see what exactly
happened here
and you'll be able to see here that
this command is executed
and
after this the next command with curl is
also executed and it passes without any
issues you will see here version 61 has
been deployed this is exactly also the
version label that we have here defined
so this again confirms that the version
that we wanted to deploy has actually
landed on the environment where we
wanted to have it
so that's about it in terms of deploying
to elastic bean stock
so just to recap we have gone through
all the stages
and we have started by
initially building our code whatever we
have here compiling it building it
running some tests
and then publishing this as artifacts
and then we have created a docker image
essentially we have created an
application
we have tested that application
and then of course we have really a
simple pipeline here we didn't
went through any other stages we
deployed directly to production but the
principles that i've shown you here can
be used for similar projects and of
course
based on all the other information that
i've shown you throughout the course you
can build power plants that are more
complex than this one but the most
important thing is to understand how you
can build such pipelines how you can
deploy them and how you can end up with
something that works and generally to
make this process as enjoyable as
possible
since now we are coming towards the end
of the course i thought it would be a
good idea for a final assignment
and what i have here is a project which
will document who has completed this
course
so what you have to do is to check the
course notes and in the course notes you
will find a link to this repository and
go ahead and click here on request
access
and
in
a few hours probably you receive access
to this repository and you will be able
to make changes to it so you can open
the web ide
and open a merge request and you will
have to add
if you wish of course your name to a
list of people who have completed this
course so let me show you how to do this
so once you have access to this you will
no longer see this part with requesting
access and you can open the web ide and
you will be not asked to fork this
project that's the main difference
and then you can go ahead and change the
files the files that we want to change
are located here in source
and the file that contains
the code is this app.js and here there
will be a table and i invite you to add
your name
and other information to this table so
for example i've added here my name i
had it here my username for gitlab but
also my country of origin and also
message to the entire world and i'm
gonna submit this as a merge request
and i invite you to do the same so i'm
going to go ahead here commit this
and i cannot commit directly into the
main branch so i have to go through the
path of creating a merge request
so i creating a feature branch with my
name
let's give it a meaningful title
and then i can just go ahead and create
the merge request
once you have access to this project you
will be able to see any other merge
requests and i invite you to take a look
at them to see what other people have
changed to make sure that everything is
working properly and if someone breaks
the pipeline in their own branch maybe
you can give people some tips in regards
to what they did wrong and what didn't
work so well
essentially be part of this review
process try to understand how to
collaborate on this project
and of course once your merge request
gets reviewed it will be merged into the
main branch and then you will be able to
see your name appearing on a web page
so i think that's kind of a nice and an
interactive way of essentially
concluding this course almost and so
yeah i hope you will do this along
in terms of editing
let me give you an advice
once there are a few people that have
been added to this list here
what i highly recommend is that you
don't just add your name at the end
because that's the highest chance that
you will run into complex so when you're
trying to make changes try to put your
name somewhere in the middle or
something like that between others try
to keep the indentation and everything
so that it looks nice
but yeah that's my advice to you
so see you
even after this course i'm gonna
collaborate more inside the merge
request try to play more with gitlab
with pipelines see how it works and yeah
looking forward to your contributions
all right you did it this is the end of
the course but don't go away yet i still
have some valuable tips for you first of
all i want to give you a final reminder
to terminate any aws services you have
created so that you don't encounter any
unexpected costs we have accomplished so
many things in a very short amount of
time i know this was a lot to take in
but i hope it was useful and that this
has opened your appetite for learning
more about devops gitlab and aws if you
enjoyed this content you could support
me in creating more courses like this
one by going to my youtube channel and
subscribing link in the video
description thank you very very much
but there's also so much more to learn
if you found it hard to work with cli
commands i do recommend learning about
linux utility commands and bash there
are also other gitlab features worth
exploring if you like working when
deploying docker containers you may also
want to learn about kubernetes for all
the topics mentioned above and anything
else i forgot to mention you will find
links in the course notes if you enjoy
my teaching style and you want to take a
more advanced skit lab course go to
vdespa.com and check out the courses
that i'm offering
if you are unsure which course is right
for you just send me a message on social
media i'm more than happy to help i hope
you enjoy spending time with me and i'll
see you next time